This is Jocko podcast number one 13 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
I instantly lifted my m four as my eyes scanned the terrain above us.
I knew without looking that John and the other guys were moving.
As soon as my weapon came up,
Reno took off at a dead sprint and disappeared 20 feet to our left seconds
afterward.
Screams came from the area.
I moved forward scanning the environment as I moved,
wanting to come to Reno's aid as soon as possible,
but unwilling to leave behind my tactical sense.
I heard three shots ring out as a Taliban fighter.
Tried to exit the shallow cut that they had been hiding in.
His companion was locked in a fight with Reno.
The dog was destroying his opponent.
Blood quickly covering the man's clothes.
I called Reno out of the fight and squeezed off several rounds as the man
reached for his weapon.
We quickly searched the area before moving on our pace even quicker than before.
The gun fire for sure had given away our position,
legs and lungs burned.
The elevation taking its toll.
As we finally reached our destination,
sitting on the edge of that mountain waiting for a ride.
I looked back at the last few hours.
I padded Reno's head twice tonight.
He had saved my life twice.
I owed him yet another debt of gratitude.
His body shivered slightly as the cold wind bid into him now that we weren't
moving,
the cold settled quickly.
I pulled off my coat and and wrap them in it,
pulling his body against mine to keep them warm tonight he had saved my life
tonight he had saved my brother's lives
and that is a little excerpt from the book Trident Canine Warriors,
my tail from the training ground to the battlefield with elite navy seal canines
by Mike Ritland,
a CEO who ended up working with dogs training dogs and eventually starting a
company called [inaudible] international that trains dogs for,
for the most elite forces in the world.
And that was an excerpt that was from an operator talking about one of the dogs
that Mike had trained.
And Mike's written two other books besides Trident Canine Warriors.
He also wrote team dog and navy seal dogs,
which is a book aimed at teenagers.
And tonight we are lucky enough to have Mike with us on the podcast to talk
about how the hell he ended up doing what he is doing.
So Mike Ritland,
welcome aboard.
It's a both a pleasure and an honor to be here.
I appreciate you having me.
So we always have to start where you started.
Tell us a little bit about Waterloo,
Iowa.
Well,
it's uh,
you know,
it's one of those,
one of those spots where I guess it's a,
it's a good place to be from,
uh,
not a whole lot happening in Iowa,
which honestly is why part of the reason why I got into dogs cause they're,
there's not a whole lot else going on.
Uh,
wrestling obviously is huge in Iowa and I had the,
uh,
the,
the pleasure of growing up during the gable era of Iowa wrestling and my dad
wrestled with Dan Gable in high school.
Um,
and so,
you know,
being kind of ingrained in that culture growing up.
Uh,
even though I never wrestled because he,
uh,
he can hardly walk and is so beat up from it,
he,
he swam.
And so all of us swam.
Long story short,
it was still a big part of my life,
but,
uh,
so I,
you know,
growing up,
kind of having that mentality ingrained,
um,
you know,
it was a big,
big proponent of,
of where I'm at today and why I got involved in both the navy and dogs because
of the appreciation for,
uh,
you know,
for that mentality.
Um,
in terms of Waterloo,
it's a,
you know,
suburban town,
70,000 people.
Um,
I'd say lower,
middle class,
probably.
Um,
a lot of influence from Chicago and Milwaukee,
St Louis,
uh,
pretty,
pretty rough high school.
Uh,
growing up there wasn't,
wasn't the best of times for me,
but,
uh,
taught me a lot of hard lessons about perseverance and doing things even when
you don't want to do them and,
and facing things that you're not,
not,
uh,
willing to,
to be comfortable with facing and things of that nature.
And,
and,
uh,
it was on the swim team and,
and,
uh,
influenced by my grandfather's in terms of their service in world war two.
And,
and just always wanting to make a,
a,
an impact in terms of serving my country.
I know I'm a little younger than you,
but for me,
I was in junior high when the first Gulf War broke out and it scared,
scared the crap out of me.
A couple of years later I was like,
where do I sign up?
Like,
you know,
that that progression,
just in that couple of year period as is crazy.
But,
um,
but it,
you know,
those,
those experiences and seeing some,
some terrorist activity as a young kid growing up,
it really,
really shaped no different than,
uh,
than how it shapes,
you know,
the guys were constantly going against and the,
and the generations growing up,
which has a huge impact.
But,
uh,
from a recruiting standpoint.
But,
uh,
but yeah,
I mean it was just,
it was something that blue collar town,
patriotic grandfathers were,
were pipe fitters and the in World War II and what they do in World War II.
So My,
my mom's dad was on a minesweeper,
uh,
in the navy.
He was a cook and a straight outta navies,
Steven Seagal just to cook,
but he was just a cook.
But he,
um,
he was on a fleet of mine.
Sweepers was 98 and the fleet in the Mediterranean and the two of them came back
and he was on one them.
Um,
my dad's dad was in the army.
He actually just tells you how times have changed.
He,
uh,
he beat an out in English,
allied soldier to death in a bar fight somewhere in Europe,
uh,
during the war,
and they just send them home and discharged him.
Um,
you know,
but,
uh,
I didn't,
I didn't know him real well and I met him a couple of times.
He had a pretty rough,
rough go,
um,
you know,
after,
after the war and,
and,
uh,
it was basically an alcoholic and I only saw him three or four times maybe
growing up before he died.
But,
uh,
but my mom's dad has,
it was a huge influence.
You know,
I talked with him a lot about,
I was always fascinated by,
um,
you know,
his stories and his outlook and,
and uh,
just,
you know,
he wasn't,
it wasn't,
uh,
you know,
aversive to talking about it,
uh,
enjoyed talking about it.
But,
uh,
yeah,
just,
it was very inspiring and it just made me want to serve.
Uh,
you know,
I've,
I've kind of always leverage my decisions in life on how I'm going to make the
most bang for my buck and get the most out of every decision.
I felt like,
uh,
you know,
it was,
it was my,
my turn to,
to,
you know,
carry the torch for a little bit.
How'd you hear about the teams?
I was a popular mechanics article that I read when I was in like ninth grade.
Uh,
and that was the first time I'd ever heard of it.
And it showed,
you know,
like,
to me,
like one of the things that I think recruits,
a lot of us is saying that it's,
it's actually the toughest military training.
They weren't by default,
I'm going to go do that then for sure.
Uh,
so that was part of it.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
I mean I read that,
that,
and that was at a time when I was getting,
you know,
I got to,
got rolled up pretty hard a few times in high school and got jumped.
Yeah.
You were talking about that in your first book.
You got rolled up a couple of times and beat down.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
I was,
I was a runt in high school.
Like my freshman year.
I was five,
405 pounds.
That's fun.
And then that was when it happened,
you know,
juniors and seniors just wailing on me and uh,
I didn't,
I didn't have much of a chance there,
but,
uh,
you know,
and even when I graduated,
I was the same height I am now.
And I weighed one 40,
you know,
so when I,
my first,
uh,
first id in the navy,
I was one 45 and I'm five 11,
you know,
so,
uh,
yeah,
I've,
I've put on a few pounds.
So did you,
did you do die fair program or anything like that?
I didn't.
I,
uh,
when I,
I originally tried to be a corpsman and,
uh,
at that time this was [inaudible] 96 they were like,
yeah,
we're pretty heavy on Corman pick something else.
And it was like,
how about Intel specialists?
You know?
So I went to Isa School right out of boot camp and I,
when I graduated high school,
I was 17 still.
So I had to wait until I turned 18 to go to boot camp.
Uh,
so I went to boot camp in August,
uh,
Isa School and,
and checked into buds,
uh,
in spring of [inaudible] 97,
but I was the youngest youngest guy in the class and the whole,
the whole deal.
And what did you weigh then?
Uh,
I worked out pretty heavy in a school.
I got up to about one 55.
I think.
So,
yeah,
I mean I have to,
I mean I see pictures of a like,
you know,
Post Hell Week and first phase.
Like I look at,
I just broke out Auschwitz.
Yeah.
I mean it was nothing to me.
But um,
our,
we'd won 75 when I showed up saying,
yeah,
five 11,
one 75 and I weighed one 85 when I graduated because I put on 10 pounds.
I weighed one 65.
I think if you're a little bit scared cause I was like a scrawny,
I know one 75 might not sound scrawny,
but I wasn't,
I was,
it was pretty scrawny one 75.
And then they,
they put a little meat on the bones as they say,
because you can eat whatever.
I would order a Domino's cheese pizza,
extra cheese pizza.
Just about every night I had the same similar ritual.
You remember the country store.
Uh,
so at the end of every day after dinner I would go to the country store and
there was that little Mcdonald's next to,
Oh yeah,
you'd get some that think I'd get a quarter pounder with cheese value meal.
And then eat that.
And uh,
a box,
literally a box of 10,
uh,
oatmeal cream pies
and a 64 ounce let it Gatorade every night.
They're good and wolf it down.
No problem.
And I gained like eight pounds.
The thing is,
and I was telling somebody about this,
you know,
you run to chow and Yak every,
every meal you run to chow,
it's a mile there and it's a mile back.
Yeah.
And you go three or four times a day for cause sometimes you go at midnight.
So that means you're running between six and eight miles every day before you
even include any of the actual training.
So you're doing a lot of physical activity.
You can eat a lot.
You don't need a ton,
especially at that age too.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
And then you couple it with being cold most of the day.
That's true.
You're burning.
I want to what?
You're burning for calories.
It's a massive amount of calories.
It's gotta be 10 k plus the,
I didn't even think about the cold part.
Oh yeah.
Cause you are just cold all the time.
Just a hammer and calories away.
Um,
did you get done with buds and,
and you,
you were a swimmer,
right?
I was.
So you're one of those people that I talk about like swimming was for you is
just super easy.
Actually,
no.
Uh,
I got,
I got rolled,
uh,
I started with two 14.
I got rolled six days before going to San Clemente island for swims.
You loser that well,
so the,
I pinched my psychiatric nerve at that look kind of doing land.
You're not a loser.
So then I just failed everything.
But you know,
it's kind of the kind of a running joke.
Like,
no,
I got rolled for swimming because it was the first thing that I,
I failed three of,
I failed everything after Laguna cause I will fit with the injury.
But I will say that,
um,
because I grew up in,
I will like my first time in the ocean was it buds.
Like,
I mean I'd been with knee high water at cocoa beach on spring break or whatever,
but I'd never been out past the surf.
I had never swam at night.
They freak you out
a little bit.
I mean it was just Kinda,
it was like an over over stimulus type thing.
But,
uh,
for me,
you know,
not having a black line to look at,
and having a guide off the coast,
um,
you know,
was it a bit of a challenge?
But that for me the biggest thing was actually swimming with fins.
Yeah.
You know what,
that's a good point because you could point people it's totally different
muscle.
Yeah.
Well,
and you know,
from,
from having swam and I grew up when I was from five until I graduated high
school.
I mean I had a partial scholarship offers,
uh,
you know,
to some local colleges for,
for swimming and,
and uh,
you know,
for me it was,
it came pretty natural.
I mean,
I was never a state champion,
but I went to state and did all right.
Um,
but,
you know,
showing it,
so growing up with that muscle memory of how to swim without ever using fins
were not the first time I put those on.
It was duck for you.
You're like two by fours,
you know,
I mean,
they just destroyed my ankles,
especially being kind of scrawny anyway.
So for the,
for first phase,
like my feet and ankles were just destroyed the whole time.
You know,
like for me it was hard to swim and I mean,
I could pass,
but I wasn't,
I wasn't,
uh,
you know,
the guys out in the front,
just turtle back and then,
you know,
having fun.
Those guys,
I mean,
there was some Olympic swimmers or water polo players.
I had a couple of those guys where I just thought,
these guys are just studs,
but they weren't swimmers.
Yeah.
So that's why I figured you were breezing through the swims to no,
I mean,
I,
you know,
they didn't,
they didn't bother me,
you know,
but I,
I was middle of the road.
I wasn't,
I wasn't blown anybody out of the water.
I think for them,
some of it is that,
uh,
you know,
an Iowa,
we were probably a little behind the power curve.
Technologywise now they do use a lot of fins,
little cheater fins and training fins and stuff.
And so there's,
there's some more to it than that.
Plus the guys that I saw that did really well were,
were more muscular than I was,
you know,
for me it was like those fins were about a quarter of my body weight,
you know?
And it was literally,
it was like having concrete shoes going for a jog.
I mean it was like,
uh,
yeah,
it didn't do me any favors.
It,
that took some getting used to for sure.
But the runs and swims,
what about the runs?
Runs no problem either.
Um,
you know,
really,
there was nothing that I,
I would say that I struggled with and I wasn't the best at everything,
but I,
you know,
I wasn't getting gooned either.
I was kind of a gray man on purpose,
which is the best place to be.
And one of my buddies,
he would say that they started the goon squad every single time with him.
Yeah,
I know.
It's quite,
if you're,
if you're slow on the run and you're get to sort of the end,
and then there's an instructor waiting and these from this point on,
you're getting gooned,
which means you're going to do a bunch of crap and it's gonna suck in the sky
was the beginning of the goon squad every time,
which is not fun.
Yeah.
So what year was it when you graduated butts?
Um,
so it was a spring of [inaudible] 98 and then you went to team three.
I went to boot camp or a Benning jump school back when they still did that.
And then,
uh,
and then from there straight to team three and an Stt and,
and I got my did the chiefs board thing,
which was a,
I wish they still did that.
You know,
I think that's a sacrilegious to do it the way they do it now.
But,
um,
yeah,
I got,
got my tried and in October of 98,
uh,
waited until January to Cla to jump into my first platoon.
And that was an Arg Alpha platoon.
So that was a 22 month workup with six months of fleet x ship deployments prior
to even deploy two arcs.
Man,
back to back our
EXEC team,
Warren Park in the tourists.
I think they're valuable.
What's ship did you do fully out the Duluth.
Oh righto.
An LPD six.
Yep.
Oh Man.
So that things from 1965 or 67 or something like this.
Some Vietnam.
Yeah.
Think they built these ships,
echo to take troops from here to Vietnam,
drop them off.
But then by the time we were on them,
they were just doing full six month deployment.
So it was straight up World War II style canvas racks.
So little canvas racks.
There'd be four people sleeping,
stacked up like four bunks with these little canvas racks.
So this is the old school.
But I will say this,
I mean
variances in terms of big navy,
like you don't get those for sure.
For sure.
And doing the fleet x as we were on the,
the Abraham Lincoln and got to stand on the bridge watching f 14 his land and
take off.
And,
um,
you know,
we got to do some pretty neat stuff that,
uh,
that I'm glad,
glad we got to be a part of it.
What was awesome for me was we were doing,
because when you're,
when you're with them,
you're with,
uh,
the Marine Corps.
And so we did all these operations in conjunction with the Marine Corps.
So I was a comms guy.
What were you,
uh,
until guy,
so I was a comms guy,
so I was always interacting with all the other units that we'd be out there for
communications and then coordinating and all that stuff.
So I had a real leg up when it came to working with conventional forces,
which if you were in a regular spec ops platoon back then,
you wouldn't ever work with them.
I mean,
you'd rarely very rarely work with conventional forces.
So I did two orgs where I got to work with marines and do massive,
you know,
battalion sized operations and it had to coordinate all of those things.
So it,
it gave me a good introduction.
You'd get,
you'd get guys back in the teams back then,
they wouldn't even know.
They wouldn't even know.
They wouldn't even understand what the Marine Corps battalion was or,
or one,
uh,
company was or what a platoon was.
They just wouldn't know.
Now everybody knows we've gotten more professional as time has gone by.
But that gave me a,
I was real lucky that I had that arc platoon experience.
I mean,
like I said,
just getting,
uh,
you know,
I know that the big navy perspective on a lot of things I think is,
is valuable,
you know.
Um,
and,
and it was just neat from a,
for me at least from a traditional standpoint.
I mean,
cause we,
we did,
uh,
about a three week exercise in Australia where we tested out a fast catamaran
that they were testing for,
for,
for us,
basically the thought was,
is this thing to do like 55 knots?
You know,
and it's the size of a,
you know,
it's bigger than like a guided missile cruiser minutes and medium sized ship
with a hole in the middle of the cat is a cat.
Um,
but so the,
the,
the thought process was we could deploy like a whole task element or at least a
platoon.
I don't know if you remember the,
I think they were with the hurricane class or whatever,
those little swm amphibious boats that was kind of the same principle and they,
they can't it after a while.
But,
um,
same kind of principle is that these things do 55 knots.
And it was weird,
you know,
we're out floating around and testing these things out,
doing,
uh,
some,
some exercises with some nor force Australian guys.
And it was more like being on a plane than a boat in terms of the way it felt
like when you're trying to sleep or whatever.
I mean,
imagine a boat that big doing 55 nights crazy.
That's completely crazy.
Yeah.
But you could put everything,
you know,
you could do a full task element loadout on it.
Be completely self sustaining and go 55 knots anywhere in the world,
you know,
so it,
it certainly had some,
some potential,
but,
uh,
obviously we never ended up doing them,
but are getting numb or implementing them.
So how many deployments did you do before the war kicked off?
Just that one.
Um,
so that was because it took so long,
it's 22 month workup.
Then you did a six month deployment,
then you come back from that.
Well,
so yeah,
the,
the kind of the,
the raw deal that,
uh,
I mean,
I guess I couldn't call it a raw deal,
but for me,
so we got back in February of 2001 mid February.
And uh,
because it was right in the middle of force 21 reorg.
Oh,
that's right.
So it was team three,
their official force 21 form up.
It wasn't until January of [inaudible].
So from February to January,
the entire team was basically like on pro Dev or,
or whatever.
And you know,
I'd only done one platoon.
So they're like,
yeah,
you're not going to free fall yet.
Now we've got two other guys going to sniper.
It's like you can go to Hazmat.
That's cool.
Awesome.
How about you can be a bus driver.
Um,
so I ended up actually going over the CISM team.
I don't know if you're that because you're a swimmer,
navy pentathlon you know,
at team three,
I was always like,
when we did run,
swim runs,
you know,
there's one thing being a little smaller at that time and being a good swimmer
and a pretty decent runner,
I could always get top three,
top five at the,
at the team on,
on any given day doing swims and runs.
And so,
uh,
I went over and tried out and made the team and competed and we were supposed to
compete in a,
is Stan bold that summer,
did the whole,
you know,
trained for six months and,
and busted my,
my backside and then,
uh,
I pull,
I pulled him are tore my groin.
Um,
and uh,
and I just,
I,
I couldn't,
I couldn't get it healed and time.
And so I ended up not,
not being able to go compete,
which really sucked.
I was,
I was looking forward to doing it,
but it was a neat experience.
So it was totally different.
It was,
you know,
the first time in my life.
And the only time it was like being a professional athlete,
you know,
we'd,
we'd train for three,
four hours in the morning and then swim for two and a half hours in the
afternoon and do a Saturday long,
long run or long practice.
And that was it.
The rest of the system stand for?
Uh,
it's,
I mean,
it's not even an English,
I don't think.
Um,
it's a,
it's basically like military Olympics kind of.
It's the navy pentathlon so it's a,
okay.
So the,
the,
the events events,
uh,
so it's,
an old course,
but it's a totally different,
you know,
it's that sort of real squirrely Oh,
course and I don't even know small.
Yeah,
you just,
it's really fast.
Like it's one of the every sprint.
Yeah.
Uh,
so there's that,
there's um,
a like a,
I don't even know what they call it.
It's like a naval traditional race thing where your paddle a little boat and you
go out around a dinghy and have to do shackles,
whatever.
What's shackles?
Well,
like,
like it's literally like you go around a buoy and have to take a shackle off and
connect it to something else.
Like it's,
so there's a little traditions challenge.
Yeah.
Um,
same thing with underwater oh.
Course.
Which that,
that one was pretty legit.
It's 125 yard underwater obstacle course.
And you got those big three foot,
um,
carbon fiber free fins on.
So you're doing,
I mean,
it's like,
you know,
like why couldn't I have these?
And you know,
but it's like you're thinking about combat swimmer,
like I'm going to steal some of these,
but,
uh,
yeah,
I mean,
so I'd say 90% of that hundred and 25 yard race is underwater.
You know,
you only come up at the,
at the end and blow out and take a breath,
like a,
like a damn Orca,
you know,
you're just like,
and go right back tasks underwater.
Yeah.
So there's,
there's a,
like a cargo net with a hole at the bottom.
You've got,
you know,
and this is over the CTT and the 15 foot sections.
So you're going from the top down to the bottom and then back to the top at the
other side.
And so the only time you're taking a breath is at the end.
And I will tell you from a physical standpoint,
like that was one of the more taxing things I've ever done because it's a race
and it's technique and whatever,
but so there's a cargo net.
You got to go under,
he got to swim a rubber m 16 from one side to the next,
holding it out of the water.
Uh,
but you're,
you know,
you're basically,
your whole body's underwater with just the rifle out and your streamline and
whatever.
It's all technique stuff that you're,
you know,
whatever.
Um,
and then you have to go down,
you know,
you go to one side and come back.
Uh,
so basically you swim the [inaudible] across,
you drop it,
you swim all the way down through that hole,
come back up.
So I'm back down to back to the other side and undo this little like firehose
shackle thing and put it back together,
come up and then sprint back to the other side type of thing.
And uh,
that,
that was pretty,
pretty challenging.
But,
um,
so there's that.
And then there's a lifesaving thing where you got to do it,
you know,
save a dummy basically,
but you have to get out of your clothes and,
and so like you're wearing these old buds greens and they're all like rigged so
that you can get out of them.
Like literally you undo the pants,
you know,
and like,
it's just an old technique thing,
but you can go from having full Greens on in the watt,
taking them off in the water by doing like this porpoise backflip thing and you
backflip out of them and,
and then go save the guy.
And it's,
it's really kinda dumb,
honestly.
Like,
it's all like,
I feel ridiculous even sitting here explaining it sounds even more stupid.
Here's explaining it to you guys,
not knowing what it is.
But,
uh,
um,
but you,
so,
so there were some underwater shit going on.
Basically what I'm hearing,
you can't go because you,
you get injured and now,
so shortly after you were supposed to compete,
if that was supposed to be in the summer of 2001 September 11th,
it goes down.
Yeah.
You,
you get rolled back into opportunity at that point.
Well,
so I,
I did a couple of Intel schools,
some a secret scroll ones that were pretty awesome during
that summer after I got hurt.
Uh,
and then I literally,
in fact,
one of them,
I flew back the night before September 11th.
On September 10th,
I flew from,
from DC to San Diego.
Um,
I get home,
September 11th happens,
I'm on my,
were living in the Hoya at the time.
I was on my way into seal team three and,
you know,
getting ready to,
to jump in a platoon when it happened.
And so obviously like with everybody,
you know,
all bets are off and figuring out what we're going to do.
There was an exercise in Jordan,
uh,
that they sent me on a couple of weeks later and they,
they beefed it up pretty heavy,
like it was going to be a,
you know,
a minimal footprint.
But after September 11th,
they ended up sending way more people and a lot more resources.
It kind of set it up almost like a,
um,
like a,
like a potential five if need be.
You know,
they had a couple of platoons worth of guys and,
and you know,
people with experience and brought real stuff and you know,
kind of a contingent if if need be,
you know,
nothing.
We didn't end up doing anything but uh,
but we spent actually almost two months over there right after September 11th is
almost like a mini deployment,
you know.
Uh,
but got back from that,
jumped into my platoon in January and then it was,
you know,
full speed ahead.
Like,
I mean,
not that I know you were saying,
well,
it's not that you weren't training for war before,
but there was definitely a repurpose.
Yeah.
And then you,
you,
you deploy and you did the,
you did the oil rigs,
right?
I did.
So,
you know,
just to kind of,
lucky luck of the draw,
I guess,
you know,
we,
uh,
we were originally slated to be a,
um,
I pay con platoon.
Uh,
we're going to go to Guam and,
and when we did,
but,
uh,
you know,
so I actually reenlisted to,
to go to Arabic school and,
uh,
at Dli and that was one of my things.
I wanted to learn Arabic.
And,
uh,
so they,
they,
they were supposed to honor that and then we got re slated as a pay competent
and like not you're going to learn to Galligan instead,
congratulations.
And was like,
you gotta be kidding me.
Uh,
so I speak to colleagues,
I wouldn't say I speak to you,
not at Dli.
They,
so they,
you know,
in true navy fashion,
it's like you're not going to Arabic,
you're not going to Dli,
you're learning to Galligan.
It's going to be at north island for three months straight.
So,
uh,
it's not the same.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
I mean I can carry on a basic conversation with it,
but uh,
so anyway,
we go to go to Guam and this is like October of of o two and uh,
and then,
you know,
we're,
we did the,
the standard pay come deployment,
but towards the end of the year they basically,
you know,
the writing was on the wall,
like our racks going to kick off.
So team five came and back filled us.
And I'll tell you,
I,
I don't know that they could have been any more pissed,
you know,
like our turnover party almost was nine fist fights,
like,
but they were pretty salty about John and blaming,
but so they had to come take our place and finish out our pay common deployment
so we could go to Kuwait.
Wow.
Those guys must have been painful or beyond pissed.
There's,
there's a feeling that we won't be able to replicate for a long time,
which is guys that had never been to war,
the desire that you had to go,
cause you think you're only going to get like
one mission.
Everyone at that time,
you're like faking.
If you get to do some kind of real mission,
you'll be just completely,
your life will be complete.
And you think,
if you don't get to do that,
you're never an opportunity.
He's never gonna get there.
And,
and so that's why I can't even imagine what was going through those guys' heads
at the time.
Yeah.
I mean,
like I said,
they,
they had that exact just pit in their stomach.
Like,
we're this close and you guys,
you know,
you've already been here,
like,
and we,
it was Kinda the best of both worlds.
Cause you know,
we went to the Philippines for awhile,
which that,
that was nice speaking to Gallog very,
you know,
we were there for a month.
Um,
and then we went to Singapore for a while.
We,
uh,
Thailand,
I mean,
it was a good,
good pay,
common deployment.
Spent some time ago,
I went to Hawaii and did like a three week exercise around Christmas.
Uh,
you know,
and then,
um,
but yeah,
so,
you know,
come late January and they're like,
they fly in all of our desert stuff and totally repurpose and all of our are
crap.
And,
uh,
and then yeah,
we flew through Thailand,
Landon,
Kuwait,
set up shop at Kuwaiti naval base for about six weeks while we're getting ready.
And so during that time,
the,
uh,
the oil rig entails me being the Intel Rep,
like I was sourcing Intel from a lot of different sources.
Um,
and they,
they weren't very well corroborated.
Like some of them,
it was kind of like on one end of the spectrum it was like,
yeah,
it's not that big a deal.
And then on the other one I was like,
dude,
this is a suicide mission,
you know,
and everything in between.
And so,
uh,
it was a little,
a little bit nerve wracking,
uh,
because it bounced around a lot.
It was like,
you know how there's,
there's nobody on board.
And then it's like,
wow,
there's four guys and saw a couple eight ks and next thing you know,
it's like,
yeah,
there's 115 people and they're all suicide,
vest it up and you know,
they're going to clock off when you guys step on,
you know,
it was just,
and it just likes that have bounced around.
But during that time,
like all we did was CQC and a,
and we built actually a full scale mock up.
Now mind you,
this target was 1600 meters long.
I mean it took us seven hours to take it down and um,
but you know,
STV did a recon on it beforehand and we built a full mock up.
We mean,
I mean I say that I,
you know,
we didn't have,
uh,
the funds of some of the other units to do that stuff with,
but,
uh,
it was basically size wise,
we laid out like rec with tape,
state wood,
wood stakes in it and twine.
But just to know,
like,
Hey,
this is legitimately how wrong it is to give,
give you a real idea because,
um,
you know,
so there was birthing at one end and that's where we hit it at the beginning
because it was the middle of the night.
That's where they all were.
And so we took,
took,
uh,
it was 32 32 prisoners,
um,
without,
without really any,
any real issue,
um,
breached a bunch of doors and took down the whole birthing and,
and then swept the whole rest of the thing from one end to the next.
And like I said,
it took,
took all night.
But,
um,
so yeah,
we did that and,
and uh,
and then came back from that.
And,
uh,
and then from there
just it was basically,
hey,
you know,
everybody load up the worst kicking off.
And,
uh,
the,
the one thing I will say it was really neat about that mission though,
is that it was the entire team.
And I think to this day,
it's still the largest single in terms of,
you know,
participants,
special operations,
mission in NSW history is cause it was the entire team and the coordination
effort because there was a manifold metering station,
uh,
on the beach.
And then there's 26 miles of pipelines that were 48 inch pipes.
You know,
there was like 30 Exxon lb is worth of oil in these just in the pipelines and
the,
and the worry was,
and the reason we had to coordinate it was that,
you know,
the,
the manifold metering station,
there's people manning that and there's people on the,
on the oil rig and all that pipeline.
If they blow that,
like it's going to destroy the whole goal if you run and will be the 48 inch
pipe.
Yeah.
Yea.
I mean you'd walk around in them,
that's crazy.
Um,
and there was like four of them,
you know,
so,
um,
but yeah,
so basically we had to coordinate with,
um,
and,
and we actually had an STV platoon with us.
Uh,
so it was us in a,
in an STV one platoon that hit the,
the,
uh,
there was two different oil rigs.
There was the,
uh,
the Mei bought and chaotic and the Mena Albach her oil terminal.
And then the core Alomia oil terminal,
the k bought one or chaotic,
the grime guys took down.
There was nobody on that.
And then,
uh,
we took down the,
the one with,
you know,
with all the people on it,
but we had to coordinate it basically time at exact,
uh,
with uh,
the other four platoons from team three,
one of which was a DP DPV platoon when they were still using it.
I think that's,
it's probably the mission where they decided to can the program cause they were
terrible and they all got stuck and it was,
there was a mass but,
but uh,
you know,
so they,
they met some resistance there.
Echo the DPV is like a desert patrol desert patrol vehicle,
but it looks like I'm Dune Buggy,
like a Dune buggy.
And,
and actually looks even super cooler than debugging cause they got big like guns
when you're a kid and you see that thing,
it's your ultimate fantasy in life coming true to see this bad ass dune bug guns
with guns all over it,
rockets on it.
And you think,
oh,
this is,
if you would have seen those when you were 13 years old,
you'd say,
whoever,
whatever I got to do with my life and drive that thing is what I'm going to do.
The problem was there.
They're real specific and finicky and,
and they get stuck.
The bottom line,
it's like a,
I mean,
they're worse than Humvees.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
So they took that down and uh,
and we,
and we timed it basically where,
you know,
it was a simultaneous header or staggered by,
you
know,
10 seconds.
But,
um,
so that,
you know what the,
the,
the worry was that if we took it down too early,
then they would know a lot of the pipes and vice versa.
So,
uh,
so yeah,
we had to,
had to coordinate it pretty,
pretty,
uh,
spot on.
But,
but we pulled it off.
Um,
they managed to,
uh,
take out a few guys on the,
on the manifold side.
Uh,
we didn't have any risk,
any resistance,
um,
no shots fired other than breaching doors on,
on our end.
But,
so we a rendezvous back at a Kuwaiti naval base and then we get it up to a
Aleasa Aleem air force base in northern Kuwait.
And then spent the next few days just bloating,
four Humvees out.
And,
and again,
this was the start of the war.
We actually only had three.
And,
uh,
we ended up,
we snaked one from the air force and,
uh,
I don't even know if I should say it,
I'm going to say it anyway,
but,
uh,
there was a green,
green Humvee that couple of our guys walked over to a parking lot and stole it
and uh,
it brought it,
brought it over.
And we spent one night literally with two cans of tans paint and the paint brush
and just painted it Tan and then a,
these were soft doors.
We had extra crappy body armor that we'd hang in the doors to try to,
you know,
give us some protection,
whatever.
And uh,
yeah,
we just were like,
well,
we're,
we're loading up.
We did have a guy,
it was his first platoon and he was,
he kind of lost his,
uh,
lost his marbles on the,
on the hit.
Like he was,
he was rattled to the point where,
you know,
he basically gave up and a,
and hung it up,
didn't come with us.
He was a 60 gunner.
And uh,
so yeah,
we had a,
had an intel guy at the time that was not a team guy that is now,
um,
that jumped in his spot.
Basically.
We talk about like old school.
Like I know they wouldn't,
they wouldn't let that stuff happen now.
As big as like,
here's,
here's a,
here's a 60,
you know?
Yeah.
Sitting in the door.
And that's cool.
That's also interesting.
You know,
people always,
it's one of those kind of myths or,
or misconceptions where people think that everyone,
that's a steal.
It's like go do 100%.
And there you go.
You got a guy that did one operation and said,
I'm not going any further.
I remember
Laura,
I think there was a couple of guys on the west coast that,
that turning their birds in after nine 11,
you know,
they're all like,
I didn't sign up for this.
Like what did you sign up for it?
Yeah.
You know,
but um,
yeah,
I mean,
and there was a couple of instances to where,
uh,
you know,
you'd,
you'd find out things about guys that just like being a bud's instructor,
um,
don't ever count anybody out.
Don't ever bet on it.
Yeah.
Cause there's people that'll surprise you both ways.
You know,
I always feel like somebody was asking me that the other day.
I was feel like you can,
you can get an indication,
right?
Like you,
you know what?
This guy pretty hardcore.
Yeah.
I,
I'd go,
I'd go 80%,
you know,
maybe 90% and you think,
oh,
this guy is pretty weak.
I go 80%,
90%.
But there's,
like you said,
there's outliers or there's people that you just think of what the,
what,
what just happened to that guy.
And it's another thing I'm having,
I'm having to contend with now as I get a little bit older is the fact that even
though I'm all about human nature and all this stuff and like I really want to
understand people sometimes I just looked at him like,
I don't literally don't understand what your problem is.
Like why would a big one,
so there was a,
there was a navy ship out in front of my house the other day and I took a
picture of it and I sent it to like Lafe and JP and,
and Dave Burke and infant Cochran.
And I was like,
the navy was good to me,
but
I don't miss these big great monsters.
Right?
Yeah.
And Lafe wrote back,
you know,
he's like,
yeah,
I mean that was my motivation going through buds.
There's no way in.
And everyone kind of agreed.
Everyone was like,
yeah,
there's no way I was going to quit buds and go to a ship,
which is not exactly,
well,
if you have the personality where you think you want to go to buds than being on
a ship is completely the opposite of that personality.
So I don't understand how a guy could be,
you know,
get,
get to a point where they say,
you know what,
I don't want to be wet cold anymore.
Which is really all it is.
You know,
people get all excited about seal training,
but you're wet and you're cold and you're tired.
Okay.
That's,
that's,
that's not that big of a deal.
The pamphlet is 10% of the job.
Yeah.
Check.
So you get some people that did,
I guess they don't really want to do it.
Everybody wants to be a frog man on a sunny day.
That's another,
a good sane.
So,
so you guys pushed up into Iraq?
Yeah.
So we,
we rolled up and the neat thing at the time was a,
it was madness was the,
was the,
you know,
he was the boss of a one mar div at the time.
So we rolled up with the First Marine Division linked up with the 13th or 15th
mew and Naza Rhea.
They had taken some,
some heavies and answer.
He was a big fight.
And,
uh,
and so the,
the,
the word that we got,
and I mean,
again,
you'd have to talk to,
to Harwood and madness if that's how it went down.
But basically we got Maddis called Harwood and was like,
hey,
you know,
some of our supply routes and,
and convoys of been getting it handed to them and,
and some,
some routes and Naza Real,
you guys go ambush the ambush or,
and like Haley.
Yeah,
we will,
you know,
so,
uh,
it was like the wet dream of,
of,
uh,
of what you would think you're getting yourself into combat lies in terms of it
was,
you know,
hey,
our conventional guys are getting,
getting it taken to them.
Here is your,
your grid square basically.
Uh,
the,
it's you,
it's your territory.
Let us know what we can do to help you,
you guys have at it.
And,
uh,
we had some leadership at the time that,
was not that crazy about cutting us off lead,
you know,
and,
uh,
so we battled it out with them and came up with some creative ways to go out and
work anyway.
But,
um,
but we just,
you know,
we went out and did like old school,
conducting our own everything.
You know what I mean?
We,
we gather our own intelligence.
We grabbed a few guys and,
and asked around and,
and,
uh,
you know,
did,
did several hits based on the intelligence that we've gathered and,
and,
uh,
had air support and it was kind of like a little microcosm of what was to come.
But was that the first time you saw dogs and action?
No.
Okay.
Nope.
It wasn't until after that and it wasn't even seeing them.
It was a hearing about them.
Uh,
which I'll get to in a,
in a second,
I guess.
But,
uh,
so then as Maria thing,
we were there for a few weeks,
uh,
just doing our own,
doing our own thing basically.
And then we went up to,
uh,
southern Baghdad,
just south of Baghdad and were there for just a couple of days and we were in
northern Baghdad.
We hit a Scud base,
which was cool.
Um,
you know,
took a Scud base down and,
and uh,
got,
got some pretty neat photos and experiences from that,
from that.
But a trick down to Scott Pace.
Got Cool Pics.
Yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
got the tee shirt.
Um,
so,
uh,
so after that,
then we went up to,
to Crete.
And so this was,
you know,
again,
this was during the conventional phase,
so it was kind of,
to me the unique part about that was,
was kind of the best of both worlds.
And it was like having box seats at a,
at a historic combat scene in terms of big conventional forces moving through.
You know,
there were,
there were lines,
you know,
everything.
Um,
and so,
you know,
I don't know if you remember the,
I think it was a third id.
He was supposed to come down through Turkey and in the last minute they said,
no,
you're not doing it.
So everything,
you know,
it was supposed to be meeting like that and in Baghdad with the,
the army and the Marines meeting south to north,
squeeze in Baghdad.
And it didn't happen.
Um,
you know,
last minute when they said,
no,
you can't run through here.
So it was just,
you know,
the marines moving south to north and,
and,
uh,
so we,
there was a couple of times where we'd go ahead of them and scout out some
routes and,
and uh,
got into a little bit of trouble a few times.
Um,
and then as we're coming up,
you know,
to create and,
and Mozal and,
uh,
you know,
tallow far and,
and uh,
you know,
some of the Curd Kurd areas up there,
they weren't real worried about to,
Crete was kind of the last big one that they were worried about being alas,
Dan,
cause it was Saddam's hometown,
whatever.
And so the entire First Marine Division in seal team,
three Echo Platoon,
uh,
took down to Crete.
And,
uh,
it was funny because they're like,
you know,
um,
first first division has the West,
you know,
seconds got the north there,
has got the south and team three alcohol platoon.
You guys are taking these,
I can,
you know,
there's 16 of us in soft soft skinned Humvees,
right?
Yeah.
Whatever.
So we got it.
Yeah.
We went,
we went,
uh,
skirted,
skirted through town while,
while the entire town of,
you know,
25,000 Marines were taking down to Crete,
were sneaking our way up to,
uh,
up to the palace and we took the palace down,
which is pretty,
pretty neat.
Um,
stayed there for a little while and then ended up,
once we left there,
we've kind of bounced around and went down,
back down to Baghdad and flew out.
But,
but,
uh,
so while I was in to create a,
that's where,
you know,
we had been in,
in scenarios where the gist of it was that there was a group of marines that had
a dog with them.
And there was a,
in one of the,
the way I described it in the book was,
you know,
again,
it was hearing,
you know,
these guys are getting ready.
There was a little opening,
like a kind of a cave complex style opening in the side of a,
of a hill and they had a single purpose bomb dog with them.
Again from,
this is all just what I heard.
Um,
and there was a,
um,
uh,
a grenade,
booby trap basically had a clump of grenades just inside the doorway that,
um,
that uh,
this dog had alerted on,
you know,
and for me that was like the slap in the face light switch moment of like,
why,
why do we not have dogs?
And I had grown up in Iowa with bird dogs.
I got into hog dogs for a number of years after,
which I'll get into the kind of what I drew from that in terms of heart
intensity,
conditioning,
training,
nutrition,
breeding theory,
stuff like that.
But,
um,
but,
you know,
I'd spent a number of years prior to that dealing with dogs,
working with them,
training and stuff like that,
but never,
you know,
this focused and strategic about it,
calculated.
And so for me,
it was just from that day on,
back in March of o three,
up until as I sit here,
it was just like I couldn't get enough of it,
you know.
Um,
and I had taken a lot of the lessons I learned from training and reading and
working with dogs,
uh,
in a,
in a more informal capacity,
uh,
and applied a lot of that stuff too,
to what,
what I had had,
uh,
started implementing with a,
with the canine programs and stuff.
And so for,
for that first five years,
it was just kind of,
you know,
a student.
I mean,
I'm still a student,
but,
um,
but it was just,
you know,
training with whoever I could train with.
I'd,
I would import dogs,
I would,
you know,
go to clubs.
I'd try to work with police departments,
anybody I could work with,
I would do it.
I'd read every book,
I could watch videos,
went to seminars,
you name it.
And,
uh,
and then as I transitioned to get ready to get out after I got a,
you know,
I came back,
was an instructor for a little while,
got valley fever and last,
you know,
40% of my lungs.
And,
and then,
uh,
as I was getting ready to get out,
I,
I could either stay in and be a handler on the west coast or a start my own
company and you know,
provide dog's training,
hand their courses and make a bigger impact.
And for me that was,
I think
they just kind of breeze through the fact that you got valley fever as an
instructor.
It's 40% loss where you buy her long and it kills some people.
And that's,
that was obviously a huge piece of you saying because if you would've stayed in,
you,
you weren't allowed to do anything that had any kind of lung irritants.
Was the deal.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
so this was,
you know,
I came back and,
and,
and it went right into being an instructor.
I had planned on,
you know,
forwarding on to bigger and better things,
uh,
operationally.
And,
um,
you know,
it,
I was out at Niland,
uh,
and I all of a sudden,
just like any of us,
after you shoot a,
uh,
an 84 or a,
or a Gustaf round,
more than a couple of them,
your chest a little tight the next day I was,
you know,
the RSO during 55 of them being shot,
and so naturally like,
yeah,
my justice type,
that shouldn't be legal by the way as we found out.
So just so anyone knows,
uh,
a Carl Gustaf are on 84,
but especially a Carl Gustaf,
it's the biggest boom.
You're shooting a 84 millimeter rocket.
And if you shoot two of them or three of them in a day,
it's,
it's like you got punched in the head a bunch.
But the problem is our instructor staff goes out there and they sit there and
do,
what'd you say,
55 and five and 55 in one day.
That's not healthy bro.
That is not healthy.
And it was one of those things like,
well,
you're not shooting them,
you're just standing there so it doesn't count.
And it's like,
okay,
you know,
a typical military genius,
you know.
But uh,
so the next day,
you know,
I expected my chest and lungs and head and everything to be a little,
a little sore than normal.
Um,
but it got worse and it got to the point where three or four days after that,
it was like,
it was debilitating,
you know,
it felt like you were standing on my chest,
especially when I laid down,
it got worse.
And so finally they said,
you know,
hey,
you need to go to Bellville and,
and hit the,
hit the er and see what the hell is going on.
And so I went and,
uh,
it took,
you know,
based on,
and I can't blame bell boy,
like based on what I told them naturally they're assuming blast lung,
you know,
type type of issues,
some sort of,
you know,
uh,
explosive type of damage.
Um,
but it wasn't,
you know,
what that did is it exacerbated what,
what had already started,
which was me having breathed in Koc city in my cosis,
which is a microscopic,
a fungus that lives in arid climates and it spreads through your lungs like mold
where it gets dangerous and kills people is,
um,
is two things.
One,
your genetic makeup,
you predisposed to determine,
you know,
how,
how big of an impact it has.
The other one is how much you're exposed to and how long it goes untreated.
So,
um,
I basically,
it,
it grows through your,
your lungs like mold and spreads.
But if it,
if it goes past that,
if it disseminates past your lungs,
then it goes into your,
into your blood and your organs and your bone.
Uh,
and then ultimately it will get into your,
your CSF fluid or cerebral spinal fluid.
And into your spinal cord and go up into your brain and in,
and that's when it kills people.
And so it's,
it's Kinda like encephalitis that way.
But,
um,
so mine had had disseminated pass my lungs,
there was a couple of hotspots in my,
in my chest,
been my sternum and,
and uh,
in my chest,
bone,
ribs and whatever.
Um,
and so when they caught it,
they,
uh,
they prescribed Lamisil,
which,
uh,
is a toenail fungus medication.
But uh,
or no,
I'm sorry,
die flu can,
but it's,
it's a lot harsher than,
than,
um,
Lamis hills,
fluconazole.
And so they,
long story short,
I was on 28 times the amount that you would be prescribed for,
for a bad case of toenail fungus.
And I got down.
So here's the,
the irony.
I had gotten up to 200 pounds prior to that.
Uh,
and then I got back down.
I wait,
wait 140 pounds at the end of it,
I was on convalescent leave for eight months.
Uh,
at the time my,
my chief was ty woods.
Um,
you know,
from the Ghazi God rest his soul.
Awesome dude.
But,
uh,
so I was working for him at the time and,
and he,
you know,
just couldn't have been better.
I mean,
he,
he checked on me,
came by the house regularly.
I mean,
um,
you know,
I mean,
I couldn't do anything like I slept 20 hours a day.
It was like having pneumonia in mono at the same time,
lost a ton of weight.
Um,
got down to about one 40.
Finally,
they had gotten the,
um,
the disease under control and got it to a,
to recede,
but it lays in your bloodstream,
like malaria does or whatever it,
it lays dormant.
So if I got pneumonia or a leukemia or HIV or cancer or something that really
immunosuppressed me,
it could come back.
And so that's,
it's always there.
You always have antibodies there.
But,
uh,
so,
at the end of that,
the infectious disease captain at Balboa sat me down.
He's like,
you know,
um,
I would recommend a medical retirement for you right now.
And he said,
if you want to go that route,
I'm not saying you have to,
but,
uh,
that's what I recommend.
And,
and,
uh,
you know,
he basically let me know what you want to do.
And I was like,
man,
I,
you know,
I've got a child on my first child on the way.
I have no college degree.
I had just totally caught me off guard.
Like I have no plan,
you know.
Um,
and so I said,
well,
you know,
how,
how can I stay in,
you know,
he said,
well,
you got to stay away from,
from lung irritants for a few years.
Honestly,
he's like,
to make as good a recovery is you're going to make,
you've got to slowly get back into shape and put weight on.
You got to take really good care of your lungs.
And me stay away from harsh cleaning products,
smoke,
you know,
dust,
everything,
which is basically everything you do as a seal.
Yeah.
I mean,
every thing that you do,
your cleaning stuff,
your bone stuff up,
you're setting stuff on fire,
you're shooting guns with led and it's just a disaster for your lungs.
And so,
you know,
really the only potentially logical xsplit era,
choice was to go over to,
uh,
to the center as a basic,
you know,
bud's instructor.
And so,
ah,
Bro,
the,
the master chief that was,
that was working for at the time,
uh,
you know,
can't,
can't say enough good things about him.
He hooked me up and made a deal with it,
with the training master chief and they sent me over there and I spent three
years there,
which,
you know,
was an amazing experience too.
And,
and I honestly,
I've drawn a lot of lessons,
uh,
from being an instructor to both life and to training dogs,
which I know we'll get into,
but,
um,
you know,
so it was neat to be behind the curtain air for a little while and see,
see what the wizard's us,
so to speak.
Uh,
but,
you know,
then when I,
like I said,
I,
as I was there,
I started,
that's when the West Coast Canine program was,
was coming up online oh seven,
oh eight timeframe.
Um,
and,
uh,
and I went and did,
did some decoys training with some of their guys,
uh,
up at a vendor they were using up in central California,
and as almost kind of like a working interview,
basically if,
Hey,
is this something you want to get involved with?
And I was like,
yeah,
absolutely.
And so they basically,
I was at a crossroads.
I said,
you know,
if you want to re enlist and whatever,
you can come,
come be a handler here.
Um,
you know,
or that's it,
and,
uh,
I thought about it for awhile and,
and for me,
you know,
it's one of those forks in the road that there isn't a right answer.
You know,
I wouldn't be where I'm at today.
Uh,
but I'd be,
I'd be lying to you if I said there isn't part of me that wishes I had stayed
in.
I'd still be in doing deployments as a handler.
I'm,
I'm sure you know.
So,
um,
but for me again,
just kind of back to like when I first joined the navy,
I've always looked at it as how can I make a impact,
not,
not what do I want most personally,
but what,
what's going to make a more of an impact in terms of,
of the industry and,
and helping more people.
And to me it just made sense.
If I can sell,
you know,
lots of dogs and,
and provide handler training and run courses and,
and source nice dogs to feed the program and all that,
then then that makes more sense from a big picture standpoint.
Did you ever get connected with any of the Vietnam era dog handlers?
I did.
A team guy actually.
Yeah.
Like do you ever hear stories about Prince Prince?
Prince was like the,
the uh,
I believe was the most successfully used dog in Vietnam by the seals,
was a dog named Prince.
I,
I heard stories when I first got in about Princeton.
And one of the stories that I heard,
and again this is the story of,
it's an oral tradition that's been passed down,
but the story was that there was guys that were getting extracted on a
helicopter and that they all piled,
it was a hot extract.
They are all the guys pile into the bird and they've got prince the dog with
them and the guy says,
uh,
you know,
hey,
we're too heavy to take off.
Somebody got to get out.
And this is the air crewman looks at,
looks the looks of the chief and says,
Hey,
we're too heavy to take off.
Somebody's got to get out and looks at the guy and looks at prince like get the
dog out of here.
We've got to take off.
And the story goes that the handlers seal handler like put his hand on on the
dog and was like,
none of us are going anywhere.
And they had to just crank the engines and real barely be able to take off.
But that was the,
that was the,
the story that I heard about and there's pictures of prince you can see in the
archives.
So I was just wondering if you ever talk to any of the guys that were any of the
prints handlers?
Uh,
not,
not that I'm aware of.
There's,
there was a guy and,
and you know,
I actually never talked to him about what his dog's name was.
I'm sure if it was him,
he probably would have told me,
but there was,
I think he was the first Vietnam Seal Canine handler that I talked to you right
as my first book came out and send them a signed copy and uh,
you know,
talk to them a little bit as I was,
as it was coming out,
which was for me just to,
it was an awesome experience,
you know,
like hearing this guy talk,
like it was basically like,
here's a dog,
figure it out.
You know?
I mean that's about the gist of it.
Apparently they had some hard times the fruit,
they didn't know what they were doing.
Yeah.
And I took a couple of deployments before they figured out okay.
And they got the dog prints up to speed and apparently he saved a bunch of guys
over over
time.
Yeah.
I mean,
he had some pretty interesting things to say about the program and the efficacy
of the dogs back then.
And yeah,
I mean a lot of it was them just kind of working their way through it.
And that's the thing that,
that I think most people,
um,
pro,
there's probably the biggest misrepresentation of,
of canine programs is that it's not a weapon system.
You know,
where it's like,
okay,
your mark one motto team Guy,
like you'll figure it out.
Like it's a totally different animal,
no pun intended.
It is.
I mean,
like,
you know,
the,
the podcast you did,
uh,
with the sacs,
right when he's talking about horses and it takes 10 years.
It's,
it's that way with dogs.
It really is.
I mean,
because it's,
it's a totally different deal.
Uh,
it takes years to get truly,
you know,
I would say that too,
to be able to master,
you know,
what it takes to implement a dog program.
It's,
it's,
it's a kin to flip it on,
uh,
another detachment or saying,
hey,
we're going to create a female special forces unit.
Like,
it's going to take a long time before that.
That's up and running and dog programs are very similar that way.
So it's hard enough when you've got training,
cadre,
resources,
you know,
budgeting,
building,
all that stuff in your favorites.
Still take several years,
you know,
to just say,
here's the dog,
figure it out.
Like math.
That's a,
that's a tough pill to swallow.
Those guys did it,
you know,
just like,
just like any of us,
you know.
Well we'll figure it out,
but,
well,
all right,
let's,
let's get into the book a little bit cause I think that'll just guide us.
Um,
cause I had a great time reading this book.
as you know,
I have a dog as well,
which is man is man biter.
Yeah.
Uh,
but the book that I decided to go with,
you got three books out.
Obviously the,
the,
the seal team dog is like book more.
It's a,
what they call in the,
in the literary industry.
It's a why a book for young adults,
right?
That's what it is.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
it's,
it's actually a navy seal dogs is the young adult adaptation of trying to keep
[inaudible] so it's the same,
same
same book.
So don't buy that one if you're an adult,
you don't get both of them.
Don't get both of them.
But then this book team dog,
how to train your dog and ABC away in Wa,
but we'll reason and he,
as soon as I,
as soon as you got here today,
you're like,
you know,
I just got listened to the last podcast with de sacs and there's so many
parallels.
You'd be surprised.
And I was like,
he's like,
are we going to talk about that?
I'm like,
of course we are,
because that's,
there's so many parallels between how you lead a dog and how you lead a human.
As awful as that might sound,
it's absolutely true.
100%.
Uh,
one of the things you kick off here and,
and I kind of skipped to the middle of the book because it's talking about
selection.
So I'm going to go to the book here.
Selection is crucial.
I can't emphasize this poison that point enough.
In most cases when I've been asked to intervene in problem dog situations,
what I instantly see as Mitch Matt mismatch such as either a slightly built
person or an elderly couple who have a 75 pound high energy dog who they can't
walk without being dragged along.
Those people are physically incapable of exerting enough force to stop that dog
for moving unnecessary first step in getting a dog to walk properly on a leash.
That's just one example of how better selection could have resulted in a better
relationship and again,
that's a real obvious one.
That's one of the easiest ones to understand,
oh,
I'm a small old woman and I can't get a hundred pound dog to drag me around,
but there's a lot of,
a lot of other characteristics that are way more nuanced.
For instance,
a dog that is super high energy and you're a working person that's busy all the
time.
You got to work when you're home and you're going to have that dog nipping at
you all the time.
Play me,
play with me,
play with me.
That's not going to be a good match.
That's not going to be a good match at all.
Um,
and,
and you see,
well you were quoting some of the quotes,
uh,
about,
I mean,
tell me a little bit about dog ownership in America right now because I think a
lot of it selection has a lot to do with where we ended up with problems.
So there's two things really.
I mean,
dog ownership as a whole is a,
it's a goat rope,
honestly.
And that's where this book stems from.
That's where my,
my team dog online training programs stems from.
And frankly,
the,
the campaign that,
that the,
I'm about to launch that that is in essence the crux of the problem with,
uh,
with dog ownership in this country is that it's,
it's mismatched a poor selection.
And,
and most importantly,
it's just a,
an inability to communicate properly with the dog.
Uh,
and,
and what that stems from is very simply as that,
you know,
dogs minds.
Um,
if,
if you think about it from,
from the most basic standpoint,
you can,
is that,
you know,
you were having this conversation verbally,
right?
You,
your dream in a language.
We're talking a language you think in a language.
Uh,
we communicate overwhelmingly verbally.
Now when you think about about dogs,
is that just something as simple as,
as you and I meeting?
Uh,
if,
if I come over and I shake your hand and we smile and nod,
you know,
touch your shoulder or whatever,
walk away.
If somebody can see that from across the parking lot and no.
Yeah,
it was a cordial,
cordial greeting.
You and I stand up next to each other and we're looking at each other like this
and doing this kind of stuff and sizing each other up and turn around again from
across the parking lot.
You know,
there's two dudes are about to brawl now,
if it's that easy for us as human beings who are overwhelmingly verbal and how
we communicate to,
to pick that thing up.
Now imagine a dog who's never thought in a language,
uh,
who doesn't dream in a language,
doesn't communicate in a language.
Now,
now think about how important body language and nonverbal verbal communication
skills are.
It's everything to a dog.
And so their,
their mind,
uh,
is an algorithm.
It works like a calculator.
It doesn't work like,
like our minds.
And that's,
that's the biggest single crucial element where people make the mistakes is the
anthropomorphize and they attach all these human associations,
emotions,
logic and reasoning to a dog's brain.
And it doesn't work that way.
You know,
the,
the a plus B equals c,
you know,
the scientific jargon is antecedent plus behavior equals consequence.
But just think of it like a calculator is that grabbing the leash plus putting
it on,
you know,
grabbing the leash a plus,
putting it on B equals we go for a walk.
See when a plus B is paired enough times to where dog anticipates,
see that's when you have problems.
How many people have you seen,
you know,
that have a dog that they grabbed the leash and he's just,
spinning around the moon and they can't even get a leash on him to take him for
a walk,
let alone settle down.
That's why is because every single time you've paired a plus B,
it's equaled c and now he's anticipating when a,
and he's anticipating,
see when a and B are present.
So something as simple as breaking context gets rid of that.
You know a lot of people,
let's put a prong collar on,
it was putting an equal,
it's a Niamh and the ribs,
let's manhandle him all these things.
All you have to do is break that context,
you know,
and,
and it's really that simple as that.
Whether you're trying to build it or whether you're trying to break it,
the process is the exact same.
You're either going to make a plus B equals c enough times to where you want
them to anticipate it.
Or if c is something you don't want anticipated,
you're going to make a plus B not equal.
It's so with Alicia example,
it's,
I go grab the leash,
I click it,
I wrap it around my waist,
I go sit down on the couch with it and now the dog is looking at you like his
mind's blown.
He's like,
what the hell is going on?
We're,
we're supposed to be walking right now.
And then I get up,
I put it back and I go sit down and go about my day.
You do that enough times and now when you grabbed the leash,
he doesn't mean anything to them.
Uh,
so just as one simple example,
if you think about all of these different behaviors that we as human beings
inadvertently create a in the animal that that is why is it's a,
it's a lack of that understanding that their mind just works differently than
ours.
As soon as you understand that coupled with presence,
you know,
I know you,
you have to speak about this in,
in your,
in your business leadership,
uh,
conferences in,
in how you carry yourself,
how you interact with people is huge.
You know,
and if it's,
again,
if it's that big with people,
I mean,
you know,
you're the type of guy that,
you walk into a room,
people are like,
this dude's running,
running the show.
Right?
Um,
a lot of people,
you know,
that we've worked with or worked for our like that just command respect by the
way they carry themselves by the way they walk in.
And if it's,
again,
if it's that effective just with us as human beings who aren't driven that way
primarily.
Now imagine a dog like a,
I do exercise of dogs all the time is right.
I don't say a word to him.
It'd be the first time I've ever seen a dog.
I'll put a three foot leash on them in a room with basically nothing in it.
And this is a dog that,
you know,
they've had all these problems with.
It's a nine month old,
crazy high energy dog.
Um,
I did it just the other day actually on the,
on the trip I was on before this,
this training facility was having trouble with this dog and they wanted to go
to,
to using some,
some compulsion methods,
some,
some prong collar and blue collar stuff to,
to get the dog under control.
I said,
let me,
let me mess with them for a minute.
So I connect the leash to them.
I walk around with them and it just,
you know,
talking on deletion and feeling him,
getting a feel for his personality.
But you know,
if you think of it like a,
like a bumper or a,
a buffer is that you're,
you're the buffer between that dog,
his mind and,
and,
and the stimuli and everything that goes between your,
you're almost the gatekeeper.
Uh,
and so when you,
you have to get inside that dog's mind and be able to reach it first,
you know,
which,
which means I have to mirror what I want out of the dog.
If he's a spazz,
I can't treat him like a spazz.
I can't spazz out and yank him and yell at them and,
and get all,
all up in his grill about it.
I need to throttle it down and,
and,
and be a mirror or a representation of physical representation of what I want
out of him.
And so it got to the point where I finally got him to just relax,
lay down,
and I could get up and walk around the room and he,
and he wouldn't move.
And he had not done that before.
And it's not,
it's not anything crazy magic wizard stuff.
It's just a basic understanding of,
of canine psychology,
operant conditioning.
And the four quadrants,
uh,
but,
but most importantly,
it's,
it's that nonverbal communication aspect that a,
that with dogs is just imperative.
Um,
when you,
uh,
the other thing that before we move on past selection or we get a little bit
more,
but a lot of times people figured they want certain breed of dog.
Right?
And I had a great conversation.
You wouldn't,
when I was getting a dog a while back and you were like,
look,
you could have a great dog that's a month.
You could have a great dog that's pure bread,
whatever you name it.
You could have a horrible dog that's a Mutt and you can have a horrible dog
that's a pure bred,
whatever you want to name it.
Or whenever that breed is,
there's the,
the,
the breed that you get.
Obviously you got to look at how big it's going to be and what kind of
temperament.
Put the temperament thing,
how,
how well is that temperament thing and how much,
how much impact does that,
does the breed and the temperament align?
So I would say that there's,
there's basically two categories.
There's the working varieties.
And the non working varieties when it comes to nonworking varieties and other
words,
your average domesticated house pet,
honestly it's,
it's a paint job and in my opinion,
uh,
breed really is what do you like,
what do you like,
what,
what does,
what does it look like and what do you like?
Uh,
it's purely aesthetic or almost that way.
because they are bred for aesthetics.
They're not bred for working,
working traits don't,
you're talking about mountain was shepherds Cata Hulu is coon dogs,
you know,
Terry or types rat,
terrorist pattern sales,
whatever.
Any type of dog that was bred purposefully.
Now it is a different ball game.
Now I would say that,
you know,
most mountain was as an example.
Uh,
you know,
do have a higher level of energy,
a higher drive that doesn't necessarily translate to good driving.
A lot of people make the mis mis conception that now my dog has tons of energy.
He just needs a job.
He needs to work.
And He'd be a great working dog.
Not necessarily,
you know,
it could be nervous energy,
it could be anxiousness.
Uh,
could be thin environmental nerves.
There's a lot of different reasons.
But back to your,
your question is that from a selection standpoint,
you know the,
if you're talking about any breed that you're just getting,
it's an Akc dog or,
or even a shelter dog or whatever.
That's,
that's not bread from three,
four,
five generations of lineage that's,
that's been selected because it brings certain working traits to the table.
It's a good dog is where you find it.
You know,
it really is.
I mean it's,
it's one of the parents,
like if it's out of a shelter,
just go evaluate the dog with the same tips that,
that I gave you.
I want to say it and I do that.
I don't care where the dog's coming from.
It could be the best bread dog from the most pipe hit or rich parents I've ever
come across.
I'm still going to evaluate that dog with,
with,
uh,
zero Kennel blindedness with no bias whatsoever.
I don't care if it's a friend of mine,
I don't care if it's puppies.
I raised,
I,
I wash out puppies that I,
I breathed and raise all the time because they're just not what I need.
And that's from a selection to tie in the seal teams and having been an
instructor there.
The reason I think that not,
I think the reason that that the caliber of individual that shows up at a seal
team is,
is so high is because buds is such a tough selection process.
I asked her the other day,
like,
people ask me what you know,
did you learn how to deal with stress?
Did you learn in buds?
And I'm like,
no,
you don't actually learn that.
You just,
if you can't,
you go away.
They don't,
there's not a class where they say,
okay,
when you start feeling stressed,
here's what you do.
Or when you start feeling like you can't go any further,
we want you to repeat this mantra.
I don't know.
They don't do that.
They just put you in crappy situations and if you want to quit,
you quit.
There's no education there.
I think the only education that exists as you learn who you are,
that's a good point.
But no one teaches,
you know,
I mean it's the,
I guess,
I guess the,
the environment is what teaches you that.
The,
another good thing you wrote in here and you just talked about a little bit,
dogs are meant to be active and are happiest when they're doing something.
And the reason I highlighted that one,
cause it's the same thing with people to,
same thing I've been talking about with Joe Rogan is the same thing I've been
talking about with Jordan Peterson.
You know,
with Joe Rogan,
we were saying that,
you know,
you need some kind of a struggle to make you feel like you're accomplishing
something with Jordan Peterson.
It's,
you know,
we talk about to Al,
if you take up the burden of responsibility,
that's what gives you a purpose.
And so for dogs,
if you're just gonna let your dog dog run around and do whatever he wants,
well he's not really going to be happy.
Is that the point?
It is.
And here is a,
I would say classic example of,
of us as humans,
uh,
anthropomorphizing certain elements to dogs.
By that I mean that we,
we look at it as a job,
as purpose,
right?
Again,
this is my opinion.
I'm not a world renowned,
a canine psychologist,
but,
but I play one on TV.
Uh,
but you know,
the,
the fact is is that,
you know,
dogs I don't think have that,
that depth of understanding of purpose they have,
what I would,
I would classify it as,
you know,
like a five year old is they have a need to be stimulated physically,
mentally,
emotionally,
socially,
nutritionally,
everything.
Just like we as human beings and where you see problems,
and I see it all the time with my online dog training is that,
you know,
when people first start out,
it's,
it's kind of a reeducation of sorts of,
of saying,
you know,
number one,
you've got to put yourself in the dog shoes and I'm going to help you doing it
by structuring these,
these monthly lessons so that they're cumulative so that you can understand and
watch your dog transform and learn from it.
But what it is,
is that it's,
it's making an understanding.
It's just like with people is that,
you know,
that dog needs to have physical exercise as part of his daily regimen.
He used to have routine so that,
so that he can count on you and depend on you for providing the resources that
necessitates his life.
He's got to have a mental stimulation just like we do.
I mean,
you can do nothing but work out,
but think about the difference between a gym workout and a Jujitsu role in terms
of what it does for your mind.
Like it's night and day difference.
And so you can't just go make your dog blow his physical every day playing ball
like you.
You've got to make his mind work.
And that's where using a clicker to reinforce in shape,
uh,
behaviors comes into play because now they have to think,
they have to figure things out.
Uh,
and it is,
it's,
it's mentally exhausting or at a minimum stimulating,
and they require that.
Uh,
same with food.
Same with sunlight,
you know,
is that if,
imagine you sit in here,
you know,
23 hours a day or,
or you don't go outside,
you don't roll,
you eat beef jerky and canned goods or Mcdonald's,
um,
you know,
do that week after week after week,
where are you going to be?
You know,
across the board,
physically,
mentally,
health wise,
immune system,
everything's going to be garbage.
And so what happens is a lot of these people,
they think they're,
you know,
spoiling their dog.
I don't know when that became a positive thing.
Uh,
but,
um,
but you know,
they think that,
you know,
by not making them do things,
not teaching him things,
not enforcing things,
not having a routine in which that dog can depend on,
um,
not stimulating his mind,
not making sure that he's physically active and keeping them in good shape,
that those are all benefits and they're not
the detriments.
You know,
needless to say,
this applies directly to your kids and how you're raised.
You guys,
you just,
everything you just rattled off is basically how you end up with spoiled kids
that are lazy and unproductive in their lives.
100%,
you know,
and,
and by the way,
lazy,
unproductive and unhappy because they're not going to be happy when they're a
loser sitting around playing video games,
you know,
23 hours a day covered in cheeto dust.
That's my favorite.
The one of the things that I think,
I think
that,
uh,
is,
is really interesting to me of how dog training kind of relates to life is that
it's,
it's like a petri dish or,
or almost a microcosm of life is that no different than whether it's business
relationship goals,
leadership,
a coach with his athletes,
a teacher with students,
parents with their kids,
you name it.
Uh,
but you know,
a,
a general with his troops is that you have to have an objective.
You got to know what,
how do I want my dog?
You know,
what does a finished dog look like?
You got to know in your mind,
what is that?
Just like if you want to be a black belt in Jujitsu,
you want to own a $10 million company,
whatever it is.
If you don't know where you want to go,
you're not going to steer it anywhere.
You're gonna be floating around.
Uh,
so you've got to know that first.
Then you gotta be honest with yourself in terms of doing an evaluation,
where am I k now I know where I want to be.
I know we're on that and now it's formulating a plan and then you schedule it
and execute it.
Just like every other aspect of your life.
There was honestly no difference.
The neat thing about dog training is that you know,
you can go through that process dozens of times,
you know,
as a dog trainer especially,
but even if you just have a dog that,
that it's a condensed process that's,
that's in a such a controlled environment.
You see the cause and effect.
You see that the criteria driven algorithmic process that exists in all of life,
but it plays out and you're,
you're manipulating it,
you're controlling it.
You're,
you're directly influencing every aspect of it.
And so,
uh,
I've,
I've learned more about people by training dogs and I would have ever imagined.
And you know,
I mean it's,
it's mind numbing almost.
How much can you can learn from training dogs and how to interact with people
based on,
on all of that.
You know,
it,
uh,
it's,
it's pretty,
pretty fascinating I think.
Yeah.
No,
there's no doubt.
I got that all out of this book to uh,
going on to what you talked about a little bit,
but just to clarify what you specifically wrote in the book here,
you talk about meeting a dog.
Before we get into the specifics of that process,
I want to take a moment to turn this discussion around again and focus on you
and not the dog.
If a dog is looking for someone to take charge and exert authority over him,
in order to not burden him with that responsibility,
then you need to carry yourself a certain way.
I go back to something I said in the introduction about wanting to be respected
over being liked.
Think about the kinds of introductions and greetings you've had with people and
a variety of ways in which they've interacted with you.
How would you respond if you met someone for the first time and they rushed up
to you,
hugged you top tussled,
your hair jumped up and down in generally acted like you were the greatest
person on the face of the earth.
Wouldn't you think that or would you think that person's assessment of you was
valid?
Would you like that kind of physical contact?
Would you think that this was a great starting point for a longterm
relationship?
Would you have respect for that person?
And then you get to this point where you say,
what kind of dog is going to be attracted to that kind of greeting and that
message and the answer is a needy dog,
eh,
that's an incredible point.
You know,
you really want,
you know,
let's say you're hiring an employee and the employee you can tell just needs a
lot of encouragement even though they're all fired up,
but the more you fire them up,
the more fired up they get.
Well does that,
the person you really want to have that's going to take you there to emotionally
prod them along to get them where you want to go?
The answer is obviously no.
Yeah.
You know,
one of the,
one of the most common kind of scenario analogies that I,
I throw at people when know I do a lot of speaking and the events and
conferences and whatever,
and um,
you know,
one of the almost always offline people are like,
oh my dog,
or I need to send them to him.
Like,
that's not going to fix it.
You know,
no different than if you send me your kids,
like they're going to work well for me.
They're not going to work well for you because you're not doing it.
Uh,
but,
but think of it from a perspective,
from a board room is that,
you know,
when they say,
oh,
my dog doesn't respect me,
there's two things.
There's a big difference between respecting and,
and a and enjoying or liking.
So the first,
first example I use is the,
you know,
being at a bar.
Um,
and I'll,
I'll,
I'll save the,
the,
the heavy details,
but the gist of it is that if,
if the opposite sex is throwing themselves at you.
Do you like that?
Well,
yeah.
Do you enjoy it?
Absolutely.
Do you respect that person?
No.
You know,
so you can spoil your dog.
You can let them sleep.
And I let them sleep in my bed.
I take him for walks,
I'd give him treats,
I take them to acupuncture and he just,
he doesn't listen to me.
Like I bet your kids don't either.
And that's why,
because it's,
it's the,
it's the 19 year old at the bar that's trying to flatter yeah.
That,
that doesn't,
uh,
it's enjoyable,
but it doesn't,
doesn't Garner respect.
The second thing on a more serious note is,
um,
think of a board room,
and I use this because I talked with a lot of business folks and,
and things,
uh,
different events.
And,
uh,
let's say that you are tasked with going in front of the,
the 12 executives of the company you work for.
Uh,
and,
and you know,
your boss says,
Hey,
you're going to give a PowerPoint presentation and your job depends on this.
If you knock it out of the park,
you're getting a promotion.
You're going to be an executive.
If it doesn't go that well,
well you're going to pack your stuff and find,
find employment elsewhere.
Now I want you to think about how you go into that boardroom,
right?
And I want you to think about,
visualize in your mind interacting with those 12 executives the way that you
interact with your dog.
How would that,
how would that presentation go?
You know,
every one of them I'd get laughed out of the room.
That's why your dog doesn't listen to you because your dog,
you can tell your dog that you're his owner all you want.
You have to show him that if he doesn't believe you,
because you haven't shown him that,
guess what?
You're not.
You can think about it.
You can wish that you were,
you can hope that you were.
Uh,
the fact is,
is that,
uh,
your dog is going to believe who you show him that you are a,
and if that's a clown,
guess what he thinks you're a clown.
If you're in an emotionally in stable,
you know,
Jay,
uh,
that's how,
that's how he's going to view you if you're a Beta male because you're rolling
around and letting them,
you know,
uh,
do whatever he wants to you that he's going to view you as such,
you know,
and,
and the most dangerous combination because a lot of times you hear the word
dominance get thrown around alpha and all this other stuff.
I can tell you,
I can count on one hand the amount of dogs that I've come across that we're
truly what I would consider an an Alpha dog.
And this is a dog that even with all my experience,
all of the manipulations I can provide in terms of,
of setting the environment up to,
to make it so that I'll,
I'll,
you know,
impact him that way.
He still wants to fight me over everything,
no matter what I do and I can't get in his head,
no matter how hard I try,
no matter what I do physically,
mentally,
environmental manipulation,
you name it less than five.
Uh,
what,
what does that have?
Thousands of thousands of thousands of drugs,
thousands and five that actually need to be the Alpha male over you with
everything.
You know,
how to get in their head,
that no matter what you do with them,
they still look at,
at,
at everybody.
Like you're,
you're below me.
Uh,
a handful of them,
less than a handful of them.
Uh,
and so when I hear especially pet owners,
so I go,
he's really alpha.
He's really protective and no,
he's not a what it is.
You're just weak.
There's a power vacuum.
Yeah.
And,
and so you know,
dogs,
again,
they don't rationalize.
I don't have the logic and reasoning we have,
they be,
they come hardwired with a set of genetically inherited traits that say if there
is no nothing in charge,
if there is a vacuum,
whether I want to do it or not,
I'm going to because somebody has to.
And so when you see all of these dogs that are dangerous and and guarding of
food and and territorial and all this other stuff,
you have a dog that doesn't want to be in charge but is taking that role because
nobody else will.
And that is a absolute recipe for disaster.
And that's why you see so many problems with,
with dogs and their owners is because of that simple fact in and of itself.
Yeah.
You talking,
you know,
again,
we're talking about all these similarities.
Here's,
here's the thing.
You got in the book encouraging that kind of over the top display of affection
is the complete opposite of how you should present yourself to an unfamiliar
popper dog.
You are the one who is making the decision that you are the one in charge and
how you carry yourself into the situation.
And what signals your body language sends are something that any dog will
recognize and decode immediately.
Do you want to concede the position of power in that relationship immediately?
Absolutely not.
And again,
this is the same thing as a leader.
Now,
this doesn't mean,
and you point this out in the book,
this doesn't mean that you dominate.
This doesn't mean that you comment and you're,
you're overly aggressive.
And I talk about that all the time with being a leader.
This doesn't mean that you're calm and you're barking orders at people cause
that doesn't work either.
That,
that,
so you got to find that balance just like you do with,
uh,
with humans.
Sure.
Yeah.
There's a couple of things with that.
Again,
with dogs especially because it's,
it's so simplified,
you know,
that that,
uh,
that element is reduced to a very primal nature.
You know,
so when you have a dog that truly is dominant,
if you display that,
guess what?
You're getting in a fight.
Uh,
if you have a dog that's not that way and you display that,
what happens?
The dog is scared.
Uh,
when the dog is scared of,
you know,
different than if,
if you,
you know,
have,
have a child that's with a third grade level,
you know,
when they walk into a classroom,
uh,
or they're sitting in a classroom and the teacher walks in and they blow their
anal glands,
you know,
because they're,
they're getting ready to get whipped with rulers and,
uh,
you know,
electrocuted or God knows what else.
They're not gonna learn anything on the transverse.
If when you walk in there throwing spit wads and playing tag and ignore you
entirely,
they're not gonna learn anything there either.
So just like in all walks of life,
there's balance.
But what it is,
is it's exactly that.
It's,
it's maintaining a level of,
of emotional stability,
a calm demeanor and,
and arrested,
uh,
but calculated mind in terms of how you interact with that animal.
And it's,
it's really,
it's not hard at all there.
There's two videos that I,
uh,
in my online thing called be the man,
be the man part one,
and be the man part two where I do exactly that.
I don't say really a word.
Uh,
in essence to the two different dogs,
both very strong,
very dominant dogs that,
you know,
their,
their level of prey drive for a toy,
a ball,
a tug,
what have you,
is such that if I have it,
they just,
you know,
they,
they start shaking and barking and balancing and the,
and they'll try to take it from me even though they're both personal dogs and
mine in the past,
their drive is so overblown and overdriven that,
that it overrides everything common sense wise.
And you actually can't use that to train them because it's,
it's so,
so overdriven
but so some people are all excited about prey drive,
but you can have too much.
I drive if you're not balanced.
Um,
I would say that it's,
to me,
I would say no,
there's no such thing in my opinion for the dogs I work with,
I would say there's no such thing as too much.
There is too much to do.
Certain types of training with it.
If I'm trying to teach obedience,
focus,
uh,
stuff like that.
No,
I won't use balls and toys like that because it is too much.
I'll use food or body language now when it comes to controlling impulse and
things like that.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But it's after I've done enough repetitions to where it transfers from being a
decision to a reaction,
no different,
but you can end up with,
can you end up with a dog that's,
he's prey drive is so high that he,
you can't take him to the park and trust that he's going to,
or can you train it out of what he can train you?
Well,
you can control it and you can cap that drive by reinforcing it.
So think of it this way and this is the more drive and lack of impulse control
that dogs have.
Um,
the more,
you know,
energy,
et Cetera,
all the things that typically wind dogs up in shelters,
all of those,
those components,
uh,
or something that can,
that can absolutely be controlled.
But the thing to remember is that,
think about the first fistfight you were ever in,
or even if it happens now,
and think about where your mind is at,
it's at a very elevated state.
Just like when you see an amateur fight or the first couple of fights,
like you know they're swinging for the fences.
They blow their why,
they you know?
Whereas you see a guy that's calculated that's been doing it awhile,
he knows how to control that.
That's,
that's in essence what you're teaching the dog,
but you have to do it.
They can't rationalize that.
The way you do it as the exact same though is that you're putting them through
so many repetitions.
No different than thinking about the very first time you were on your primary
and you pull the trigger and nothing happened.
You had to think,
okay,
I'm going to put it down and it's trigger control and you're doing all the
things in your head.
At a certain point,
that becomes a reaction,
right?
When that becomes a reaction,
then you're trained.
Same thing with the dog is that you've got to do those repetitions using things
to reinforce it.
If the dog is in that state of mind,
because the,
the key component is you got to do it when they're not in that state of mind to
be able to control them when they're in that state of mind.
You have to build that foundation first.
Just,
you know,
you can't,
you can't teach a fighter how to be composed by doing real,
real matches that comes in training.
And so the parallel,
again,
his is his exact,
uh,
is that you've got to,
you've got to use a classroom.
And what I do,
I use a 40 by 40 classroom where I use a clicker food,
treats,
affection,
body language,
and I,
and I teach and shape all these behaviors that I'm trying to teach and tell.
It becomes a reaction.
And then I just slowly start to introduce distractions and graduate them k
through 12 until they're,
until they're doctors,
you know,
uh,
of going out and,
and some of the videos I have of some of the dogs I've worked with,
you know,
and one of them is a black German shepherd,
actually just sold them to a big metroplex,
a swat team.
But,
um,
I could take him through Walmart,
off leash.
I could take him to parks where kids are playing soccer around them.
And this is a dog that even if I have a ball,
he'll,
he'll bite through my hand to get to it.
Uh,
and I could get to where without using any punishment,
without using any compulsion,
just by doing,
shaping and reinforcing and,
and using,
uh,
you know,
that a plus B equals c over and over until it became a condition response.
And now the dog a works on autopilot,
but it's like your name.
You know,
when somebody says Jocko,
you don't have to think about responding.
You've heard it enough times to read.
We do that,
you know,
um,
same,
same exact print a principle.
What's up with resource guarding?
Um,
usually what it stems from is,
uh,
is an,
again,
an inadvertent creative created behavior.
Uh,
kids messing with them,
taking food from them.
A lot of times,
you know,
people,
I want to be able to take food.
I don't mess with the dogs when they eat.
Now I need to be able to bump him,
walk by him,
take it from him if I have to.
Um,
but it's,
it's when a dog has really high drive for something and you compete for that
over and over and over,
you're building,
uh,
think of it like a barrier in the dog's mind and you've got to,
your goal is to kind of hit the refresh button on the computer screen and that
dog's mine.
And so,
um,
you know,
what I'll do,
like if a dog has real heavy resource guarding with,
with food as an example,
is that now I'll feed that dog his entire ration of food from my hand throughout
the day training.
So now it's not me setting a bowl of food down and now you're going to guard it
and get,
get crappy with me.
It's,
you know,
when you do what I want,
then I'm going to mark it and reward it.
You're getting it from my hand and it just breaks that context wide open.
And now,
now it doesn't become a thing.
Um,
in the police dog a realm,
one of the,
one of the most common examples of,
of that behavior misfiring is his outing.
Uh,
when we're doing bite work and that dog isn't that crazy,
elevated state of mind and he's,
and he's overlapping pray and defensive drive and you're transferring back and
forth.
Um,
is it now you say,
okay,
let go.
Just like the first time he got in a fight,
like,
you know,
one of your buddies taps you on the shoulder,
hey,
stop fighting.
Like you don't hear that.
So to,
to reach that dog's mind when they're in that elevated state,
it all boils down to you got to enter their mind first to communicate.
But is it when they're in that elevated state of mind,
what,
what usually happens is they use an equal or a prong collar.
They grabbed their,
uh,
the dog's flat collar,
the role at twist it,
just like a guillotine choke and lift them off.
Um,
all that does is create conflict between the handler and dog and,
and it,
and it builds and creates possession over objects.
Uh,
so with a ball.
I see it all the time.
People want,
my dog won't give me the ball.
How do I get it from,
what are you doing and you're watching him.
He was chasing the guy and he's chasing the dog around with the ball.
How do I get them to let go of the ball,
get another ball,
make your ball sexier than the ball that he has.
The second he drops it,
you mark it and throw the new ball just like that.
Now the dog will spit it out for you with no conflict with no,
no problems whatsoever,
but it's that way with everything.
It's with food,
it's with toys,
it's with Unh.
We talk a lot about indifference in here as sort of a,
I don't know,
as a as like a base sort of reaction to a lot of stuff and I noticed that with
my dog.
If I want my dog to drop a ball,
I,
if I just ignore them for for for five seconds the ball drops out and then he
looks at me because he knows it's like,
okay,
can you,
can you pay some attention?
Because I want you to fill this thing again,
but I'm bend down,
grab the ball,
throw it again.
He comes back,
he wants to,
he wants to fight for it.
But if I ignore him,
just,
just look away for three seconds.
Ball gets dropped.
Bend down ticket.
Yeah.
I mean it's the same.
It's the same bar room psychology.
Why aren't you paying attention to me?
But you know,
to,
to bring it back to the dog aspect is that,
you know,
if think about it from more of a,
almost a primal nature of think about kids,
when you watch kids,
what's,
what's a very natural,
when you bring several kids together,
what do they do naturally?
They chase each other.
It's a natural function in,
in animals,
uh,
on the planet.
Uh,
dogs are no different.
So if they have something,
it's a game as much as anything.
But you can,
you can turn it into something more serious as the dog gets older and they
become more possessive and driven because you've built those barriers in their
mind.
Uh,
but in terms of the indifference piece,
100%,
the,
one of the first things I do a with the Warrior Dog Foundation,
the nonprofit that I have that,
uh,
we retire,
you know,
former Spec ops dogs and police dogs and contract working dogs and all sorts of
different dogs.
But,
uh,
the very first thing I do with all those dogs,
I have a pouch of food.
Uh,
I have a clicker a and the clicker just for those of you that you know,
to.
So the understanding I'm talking about it just a little mechanical device,
it has a button on it,
you push and it goes and it just makes it a very mechanical sound that's unique,
that pairs,
whatever the behavior is with a reward.
It's a bridging of stimulus for.
So,
um,
just thinking about it,
like taking a picture,
you know,
is that you're,
you're letting the dog know that the,
the instant of what's taking place right this second is correct and our reward
is attached to that.
Uh,
but anyway,
so I let him out of the gate and I've got a two and a half acre training field
around my Kennel facility.
And so it's just me and the dog walking around with a pouch full of food and a
clicker.
And I,
I completely ignore them.
Um,
and,
and I purposely walk away from them and anytime that dog comes over to me,
I'm market reward it,
turn around and walk away from them again.
And I'll do that for five to 10 minutes,
three,
four times a day for a few days.
And I mean,
we've taken in over 80 dogs over the last eight years in seven and a half,
eight years.
And,
uh,
to this day,
there's not been a dog yet.
We're,
we're,
that has not worked.
Uh,
and I've done it with a lot of other dogs too,
but,
uh,
is that even if they hate people,
you know,
they're,
uh,
defensive,
aggressive,
they're environmentally rattled,
the a pts type issues.
What have you,
uh,
is that,
that,
that element of you getting paid and in me shaping certain behaviors works on,
on all of them,
but it works the same way with people,
you know.
And that's one of the things in terms of something like the leadership stuff
that you do is that,
is that operant conditioning and positive reinforcement?
You know,
the,
the four quadrants.
While yes,
I work primarily in the,
in the um,
positive reinforcement realm,
I do use positive punishment.
I use negative reinforcement,
negative punishment.
But uh,
for,
for the layman,
think of it from,
you know,
if your,
uh,
your spouse's out of town and you spend the weekend,
cleaning the entire house,
right?
Uh,
it's spotless.
You know,
the kids are all in check.
the old lady comes home and the,
the house is spotless.
The very first thing that she recognizes is that the one thing you didn't do was
take the trash out.
And that's the first thing.
She's like,
you didn't take the trash out.
Like,
oh,
I guess I'll have to do that,
you know?
And that like,
that's her response.
How likely are you to clean the house ever again?
Very not likely.
No,
I agree.
Uh,
whereas,
you know,
on the transverse,
if,
uh,
you know,
she grabs a hold of yet and whatever,
um,
you know,
or gives you some positive,
reinforced,
gives you some positive enforcement,
may be in another room.
Uh,
then,
uh,
then you know,
that that speaks for itself,
you know,
so it's that same element and her call me mister clean around here and I'm,
I have to pick your head.
Uh,
yeah,
you'll be cleaning the house every weekend,
you know,
so it's,
um,
it's just,
it's a,
it's a very simple element of,
uh,
you know,
one of the analogies you could use to is it's the difference between slave labor
and a job with great benefits.
You know,
at the end of the day a task is being performed.
Uh,
but one,
you know,
the,
the level of drive,
motivation,
satisfaction,
happiness,
on one end there are 280 degree,
uh,
bipolar or despair opposites.
So,
um,
you know,
just,
it's just basic reinforcement.
But if you look at everything a dog does in that,
in that regard,
uh,
and that,
you know,
every,
every time that they do something that you want,
it gets marked and reinforced.
Every time that you,
they do something you don't want to gets extinguished and,
or corrected.
It's very black and white.
Um,
another quick example is a toys in the house.
You know,
people are like,
oh my dog's chewing this up to you and add up.
Do you keep toys in the house?
We always got kongs and other balls and stuff.
My,
my rule of thumb and my advice to everybody is a make it black and white and the
dogs might,
again,
he doesn't know the difference between a tennis shoe,
a stuffed animal,
a Kong toy,
whatever.
It's all crap.
It's laying around your floor.
Uh,
you know,
can you make them distinguish things?
Yeah,
but let's not put the cart before the horse.
I teach them to respect what you say first.
And so he doesn't get to play with anything in the house.
If he knows that nothing gets in his mouth inside the house,
other than what I hand him,
then,
then it's real easy to teach him,
don't chew on stuff.
Uh,
it's outside,
it's in a crate,
it's in a Kennel.
That's when I'll give you things to play with the chew,
with the tug,
with whatever,
and build that engagement work on the bond and relationship or whatever.
But
do you have in here,
when I see so called problem dogs,
the problem stems from an imbalance of power and relationship and not from the
dog.
So that's,
that's like the route that you see all the time.
The person's weak.
We have pretty much already talked about that.
And it's the same thing.
You see a lot with leadership where you've got someone that's that there's an
imbalance of power and where it gets more complicated with humans as humans then
do their own kind of self.
Correct.
And a lot of times they overcorrect they under correct.
You know,
if they're being too,
if they're being too micromanaging,
then they go all the way to the other side of total loss.
A fair.
And now people don't know what to do or if they're being too loud a fair they
and they go straight to level 12 a micromanagement.
And again,
it's just,
uh,
a personality thing or a mistake that they're making and imbalances the,
the relationship that we have with people.
Cause it's like,
well yeah,
I want you to tell me something to do.
I want you to give me some guidance.
I just don't want nothing.
Yeah.
And people lose that.
Um,
here's another one that's important to establish your authority over a dog.
Dogs want,
need and seek that kind of presence in their lives.
You just hammer this over and over again.
It's easy in some respects to get a dog to fear you,
but it can be equally easy to get a dog to respect you just as true with human
relationships.
A dog will have more respect for you if you make it clear that good behavior
gets rewarded and poor behavior has consequences.
You may have noticed,
I have not used the word like or love up until this point in describing the
human canine relationship.
That is not an accidental omission.
I've purposely not used those words because too far,
often I encounter people who's immediate response to a dog's to try and get the
animal to like them.
In doing so,
they make fools of themselves than dog eyes possibly put themselves in danger
because they assume that they know that how they treat their dog is okay with a
different dog.
And mistakenly believe that because of all the nice things they do for their
pet,
their dog should obey their wishes and desires unconditionally.
If you take one concept away from this,
from this beginning part of the book,
it's this don't mistake liking for respect and don't mistake obedience for
trust.
We could be talking about human beings.
It's right there,
clearly,
especially kids.
Oh,
absolutely.
And employees.
Yeah.
Because it's,
it's not a popularity contest.
Yeah.
Uh,
and,
and that's where so many parents and,
uh,
administrators or coaches or supervisors,
et Cetera,
go,
go wildly wrong is,
is worrying what somebody thinks about them.
You know.
Um,
and again,
I mean it's the,
to draw back to the microcosm of,
of the dog training process is that,
you know,
what,
what's the end goal?
Getting your kids or your employees or whatever it is to think you're cool isn't
part of the process.
You know,
it has no relevance.
Well I mean it,
it has no,
no productive productivity.
Yeah.
And what's interesting about [inaudible] used to run the job course,
uh,
the junior officer training course,
which is the guys that the young officer's coming out of buds and there was an
officer,
this is the other end of the spectrum.
There was an officer
that would come in to talk and eventually Lafe had to like back the guy
tactically out of the schedule.
Cause he would say if you're an officer and your men like you,
you're doing a bad job.
That's not what we're talking about here.
You know,
it's not that you don't,
it's not like you want your dog to aggressively hates you and you don't want
your employees to think this guy doesn't care about me.
In fact,
I talked about this a,
uh,
a little while ago.
Like the more you,
the more you care about your people,
the more they'll care about you,
the better performance they they deliver.
Right.
If they don't think you care about them,
then they're not going to deliver any kind of a performance other than the
absolute minimum that's required.
Yeah.
And you know,
from,
from the dog's perspective,
that's where,
you know,
the,
there is a little bit of a difference in that with dogs,
it's about engagement.
Uh,
you know,
one of the,
one of the examples I use is,
you know,
how many times have you been to a park?
Right.
And you see theirs and it's usually dad's,
but uh,
you know,
there's the dad sitting on the bench on his phone and his kids are swimming and
playing tag or whatever and he's oblivious.
Like they could get kidnapped and they wouldn't know any better unfortunately.
Whereas that dad that's pushing them,
that's playing tag,
chasing them around grab ass and with them,
all that kind of stuff.
Now when he back,
hey honey,
what'd you do?
Well,
I took the kids to the park,
but those were two disparately different experiences.
Now think about from the perception of where the kids are at,
the difference.
Like it's night and day.
Same thing with a dog.
You know,
and that's one of the things I'm,
I'm uh,
so adamantly against dog parks,
dog parks are the iPads to two dogs.
What iPads are to kids.
Uh,
you know,
you can't have a substitute for that engagement with them.
You know,
you can't outsource your relationship.
Uh,
and that,
and that happens way,
way too often,
you know,
again,
whether it's with kids and,
and uh,
you know,
with dogs,
whatever.
Like,
you know,
there is an element of just like with anything is that,
there's uh,
you know,
training franchises that I'm actually planning on launching here later this year
to help with that process.
But it is,
it's an augment,
you know,
and there is no substitute for,
for what you have with,
with your dog,
with your spouse,
with your children.
Whenever there's,
there's nobody that's going to be able to,
to make that work for you if you don't want it.
Just like somebody comes and make me a good,
good Jujitsu artists.
Like when you got to want it first,
like you gotta be willing to put the time in with dogs is it's no different.
To that point.
Here's back to the book.
The bottom line is that if your dog isn't doing what he is supposed to or what
you want them to,
it's not the dog's fault,
it's your fault accountability.
It's your fault for not spending the time needed to train them properly.
We're not being observant,
urban and enough to recognize early on when and how your relationship may be out
of balance.
Many people are too lazy to achieve the results they want.
If having a spectacular relationship with your dog were super easy,
everyone would have a have that and I wouldn't be writing this book right now.
One common excuse I hear all the time is I don't have time.
Well,
I can assure you,
you do have the time.
What you don't have is your priorities in the order they need to be to have a
great relationship with your dog.
This is a little bit of extreme ownership for your dog and it's not.
We say all the time,
your team's not doing a good job.
Who's fault is it?
It's your fault.
You're the boss.
That's whose fault it is.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
and,
and what I would hope,
uh,
is that the people that read that read that,
that you know that you can take that,
that self evaluation seriously.
You know?
And,
and again,
I mean,
when I,
when I read extreme ownership,
it was like,
yeah,
I said it's textbook.
You know,
it's,
it's the same,
same exact principles and that,
you know,
if,
if you're the one in charge,
guess what,
you know,
if it's not going well,
it doesn't work down.
It's not trickle trickle down responsibility.
It goes straight to the top.
And that's something I'm,
I'm out of,
been adamant about with my employees is that,
uh,
you know,
if,
if you don't underst if you screw up within reason,
it's,
it's generally going to be my fault.
Right,
right.
You know,
um,
if you don't understand what you're supposed to do or,
or,
you know,
something happened that,
uh,
that you weren't prepared for or whatever,
then ultimately it's my bad,
you know,
whether it's me putting the wrong person in a position to,
to experience that or me not giving you the guidance prior to putting you in
that experience to be able to deal with it.
Because with dogs,
it's dynamic.
You know,
just like in the workplace,
you know,
training people to,
to work with some of these dogs that we get in.
Like,
I mean,
it's,
it's no circus.
It is a circus,
but it's no joke.
Uh,
it can be a circus,
you know,
but it's the same,
same type stuff.
Yeah.
You talk about building the relationships here,
going back to the book,
working in my training of working dogs,
I still put myself in the dog's position and understand that it was important to
establish a positive rapport with that animal before I began making too many
demands on him.
So this is the crux really of of where I wouldn't say nothing that that's in
this book or anything that I subscribed to a is not anything new.
You know,
that,
I mean,
people have been,
have domesticated animals for thousands of years.
What I will say is that,
um,
I generally don't find people,
uh,
spending as much time on that,
that simple component,
um,
as much as I do.
And this is where I draw from my time with hard driven,
dominant working dogs that are biting people.
And when you get an a bite suit,
uh,
and you're working a dog,
and,
and developing him,
no different than you'd bring up a young fighters that,
that,
that is what,
what a decoys job is to do,
is to,
is to build confidence and,
and with dogs,
you know,
the nice thing is,
is that when it comes to,
to aggression,
pray in defense are two sides of the same coin.
You know,
just like a reproductive or reproduction and killing our two sides of the same
coin.
Um,
is that when I'm,
when I'm in that suit and I'm reading that dog,
I'm,
I'm exuding all of these things on him.
I'm either making him uncomfortable and putting them in defensive drive and then
when he responds,
the way that I want gives me,
you know,
aggression of responds in kind with aggression.
I,
I go back into prey drive,
take all that pressure off and reward him coming forward.
I'm teaching him to fight me and come forwardly aggressive.
Um,
but the,
the way that,
that I have been able to develop that same strategy with pet dogs is because
when you're in a suit and dealing with these dogs that are on a level 12 out of
10,
by comparison to the pet dogs we deal with is that,
you know,
you have to be so,
uh,
over overblown or,
um,
so dramatic with,
with how you're doing it to be able to affect these dogs that now when you're
dealing with pet dogs,
it's,
it's actually really easy.
Uh,
but what,
what it made me realize is just that same concept works the exact same way with
those dogs.
Is that,
is that entering that dog's mind and getting that relationship first before you
have that you are completely wasting your time doing anything else.
Uh,
again,
no different than,
you know,
if,
if you're a boss with employees or,
uh,
you know,
a,
a military,
a leader or pick anything is that if,
if there isn't trust and relationship there first as the foundation,
you're,
you're building a shanty on,
on sand,
you know,
in terms of,
of everything else,
you try to do that without,
uh,
you're,
you're essentially wasting your time.
And so I,
I hammer so hard on the relationship component because it is,
it's,
I mean that,
that's a universal truth in life.
Yeah.
And it escalates to,
the more you build that relationship,
the more you can demand.
And of course,
the inner relationship you're not demanding for people with,
the more you build a relationship,
you're more,
you can ask for someone to give to you and the more they'll do for you because
you have a good relationship with them.
For sure.
And,
and there's,
there's also a reason,
especially on my online training,
the first five months,
there's no corrections whatsoever.
There's no punishment.
There's,
there's nothing.
It's all bonding,
relationship building and reinforcement and shaping behavior that's not by
accident.
The reason why is it a lot of times people,
they don't have a relationship with the dog.
The dog's getting into x or doing y or whatever.
Let's put a prong collar and remote collar on and let's punish him.
A lot of people do that.
There's training franchises that the backbone is using remote collars,
which I vehemently disagree with.
And it's not about a cruelty thing.
It's about an understanding is that if I see,
if I have a great relationship with that dog,
and again,
you know,
the work environment,
whatever spouse,
uh,
and then we've gone the full run of shaping and reinforcing desired behaviors.
And I have clearly communicated to him and positively taught him what the
expectations are now when he's not performing up to that standard.
Now,
if I correct him and punish him,
guess how much more effective it is.
You know,
because at first it's,
you're just,
you're just some other jerk that's putting your knee and my rib cage or
electrocuting me or you know,
jerking me off my feet with a prong collar just like all the rest of them.
Whereas now it's like your dad saying,
I'm disappointed in you here.
You know,
it's,
it's a lot more impactful that way.
You know,
so it means more
dogs is back to the book dog's respect,
confidence,
power and authority.
And by dogs,
I mean all dogs,
I don't care how much of an Alpha role any dog is assumed when someone comes
along who exhibits those three traits to a greater degree than day,
they will step aside with the exception of the four,
the four that you come across.
But those,
those are,
I can assure you that nobody on the and the 83 million dog owners or pet spread
spectrum have ever run into,
you know,
these are Unicorns for sure.
What'd you do with those dogs?
Um,
bread,
some of them.
Um,
one of them was out on the west coast actually,
uh,
as,
as a working dog,
just retired here,
not,
not too long ago.
Um,
if I had to,
to pick probably the most gifted physically are across the board dog I've ever
come across.
It was a dog that,
that was out there for several years.
Um,
that came in.
We put them through his firsthand,
their course and then he deployed and did several deployments.
And,
uh,
just,
I mean,
he's a freak,
you know,
absolute freak.
But,
um,
the first year was a funny story.
The first time I met him.
So we were running our hand,
their course at Auburn University,
at their canine,
uh,
detection research institute back when it was still in,
in,
uh,
in progress.
This is in 20.
We brought the dog in and,
uh,
we were staying at a local hotel there and it's eight.
We can of course putting the dog through.
And my very first introduction to him is he was staying in the room with his
handler and they'd spent some time together and it had started to bond.
And,
uh,
it was like a Holiday Inn Express.
They had free pizza.
And,
uh,
so of course I'm like,
I'm not gonna pass up free pizza.
So I've got a paper plate with a couple of pieces of the pie on it and a,
I walk into the room and the dog just kinda cocks his head.
It looks at me,
he runs over and literally like a dude,
like a team guy jumps up and just,
just slaps it right out of my hand and he leans down and starts eating it.
And then I,
I started to lean down.
He just looks up and I,
I've been around enough dogs where like,
I was like,
you know,
I'm just
enjoy that.
Yeah,
that one's on me buddy.
And,
uh,
the first time I saw our dogs working and I forget who brought him out,
we were,
we were doing some training and you know,
we,
it was set up but the,
the task and it was doing a hit and a building and there was a guy that was
gonna run.
A decor is going to run.
And I was out there and man,
when Nate,
so I see the decoy go and you can see the dog sees it and the dog,
you,
you can feel it,
man.
This dog is ready to murder this guy as if this is just the most insane level of
passion.
And he's just on the end of that thing and that you could see the handles Latin
and Latin and blend it.
Bill letting it build that up build.
He pulls that quick release Bro.
I was like,
oh my God.
It was insane to watch him fire off.
And he took off like 10 feet to when he finally got like,
he's going a million miles an hour across this field.
He takes off about 10 feet and just nails.
This guy dragged him to the ground.
I was like,
okay,
this is a good little system to implement here.
Yeah,
no,
I mean from,
uh,
the new thing about,
I think capability wise,
um,
is that it's,
you know,
it's a,
it's a nonlethal form of,
of capture,
you know,
uh,
which is obviously very valuable.
Uh,
the deterrent aspect,
the psychologic intimidation factor.
Yeah.
That's a real beautiful thing too.
You know,
there's,
there's a lot of elements to,
to have having those dogs.
There's,
there's just,
you know,
it's amazing you see it,
especially in law enforcement.
Um,
you know,
but you'll have guys that will literally stand there with six armed officers and
fight all sex of them.
When,
you know,
drawn on getting tased,
pepper sprayed,
you throw the 65 pound pointy ears,
little,
little mountain while out,
and the dude lays straight down like,
I'm not messing with,
you know,
and uh,
yeah.
It's amazing.
I mean,
uh,
but you know,
you think about it from,
from again,
from the human component of it's not natural to be attacked by an animal,
you know,
that nor is it something that most people are comfortable with,
B have ever experienced.
Most people have mixed it up,
especially if they're getting drawn on by six officers.
It's probably not their first fistfight.
Uh,
you know,
but so,
yeah,
I mean,
that,
that element of it is,
is pretty,
uh,
it's pretty awesome.
Back to the book,
the lax permissive attitude that exists in our schools,
our homes and our society in general has trickled down into how we interact with
our pets.
While there are some benefits to our living in a kinder and gentler societies
are also some huge drawbacks.
This is particularly,
this is particularly true as it pertains to dogs.
Some people believe that it's impossible to have a well trained dog and to never
have to physically correct that dog.
I wish that were true,
but it's not the case.
Let me be clear.
I don't employ,
and I don't advocate the use of any kind of unnecessary force,
but please understand this important point.
If all you ever do is reward your dog for good behavior you have and you have no
consequences for bad behavior than your dog will not have a complete
understanding of what's expected of.
So when you were talking about,
you know,
the,
the fact that you sometimes do have to use a call,
a pinch collar,
you have to use a choke collar.
You might have to use a digit.
Was it remote color?
You might have to do that stuff.
In fact,
you probably will.
Yeah.
I mean there's,
there's always the chance.
I mean,
the,
the best way I can kind of break it down as is,
think of it from raising kids were again,
employees,
like if,
if the,
if the consequence,
uh,
is,
is the absence of reward.
That's,
you know,
you,
yeah,
she may come across a dog,
but again,
this is an outlier exception anomaly,
whatever coin phrase you want to use,
those,
those aren't realistic,
um,
aspirations to have with a dog.
Like,
just like with kids,
like,
yeah,
hey,
if you don't clean your room,
you're not going to get those peanut m and m's.
Oh,
okay,
well,
I'll go do it.
They may be like,
yeah,
you know what?
I'd rather not have peanut m and m's and just not cleaned my room.
Now what are you gonna do about it?
You know,
like you're gonna run into that as a dad.
A shock collar.
Yeah.
Two of them cattle prod,
uh,
you know,
so the,
that it's a bit of an oversimplification in terms of,
you know,
where,
what it really boils down to is,
is you know,
when,
how,
uh,
how often,
you know,
things like that.
I mean,
it,
it really is not so much a matter of if it's,
when it's just being smart about how you're implementing it.
So that a,
it's effective.
And we were kind of,
my rules of thumb for implementing a compulsion or positive punishment is,
uh,
is it,
it's not when you're emotional about it,
it's not when the dog does not understand why it's happening.
And then the last thing is that the instant the behavior has ceased,
the punishment has to also,
uh,
what you find a lot of times,
most times,
uh,
and especially early on,
if that relationship hasn't been built and that foundation isn't there.
Again,
I can't explain anything to a dog a lot.
A lot of people,
you know,
we all have our expectations.
I know I want the dog to sit.
I don't want them to grab sandwiches.
I don't,
I'm knock the kids over.
I don't want him to bark when it's three in the morning,
unless there's somebody breaking in.
He doesn't know any of that,
you know,
so we have to teach them.
Uh,
and if you,
again,
just like with the human component,
if you're trying to teach somebody something and they don't understand what's
expected of them and you're punishing them for not understanding it,
that that sucks.
You know?
And that's unfortunately,
that's how most dogs go about their lives,
is that,
you know,
I don't have a relationship with this dog.
Let me throw a prong collar and blue collar on him and make him do things and,
and he just shuts down and he's a verse of two.
It Joey put the,
uh,
e collar on people and you have them do a little task.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a,
it's a real simple,
you know,
it,
it dovetails onto this,
uh,
you know,
this kind of principle is that,
again,
so that,
so that you can put yourself on a dog shoes is that,
uh,
and so what I do when I run handler courses,
um,
you know,
let's say it's youtube.
I'm going to have,
you know,
you be the handler echo is the dogs were going to put the collar on his bicep.
I'm going to take you out in the next room,
Roger there.
So I'm going to,
I'm going to take you out in the room and said,
okay,
we're going to come back in here and I want you to get echo to take this echelon
front thing,
uh,
put this here and put that there.
That's his,
his task.
For those of you that are listening,
it's like a menial task.
It's put a pencil and a paper clip onto a box and they're going to be sitting on
the table in the middle of the room,
all separate from each other.
And there's a bunch of others.
There's a bunch of the crap here.
So when we come back in now,
you don't say anything to them.
We're not allowed to talk.
And so now echo just starts grabbing stuff.
And every time he grabs the Sharpie,
you get shocked.
He grabs the,
uh,
the,
the t,
he gets shocked.
He grabs the knife,
he get shocked.
He messes with the paper,
get shocked after five or six,
maybe 10,
you know,
he's a strong guy.
I can take,
take some punishment.
You crank it up and he's not getting it.
He's messing with the wrong stuff.
I'm going,
if I'm going to hammer him harder,
what's he going to do?
Very quickly,
he's going to do this.
He's just going to sit here and say,
I'm,
I'm not touching anything anymore.
Cause he's to be,
becomes aversive to all the stimulus stimuli on,
on the desk,
uh,
on the transverse.
And so what that teaches you is that if your dog doesn't understand that,
that that's what happens.
And,
and that's the position you're putting your dog in is the very one you're in.
and,
and it sucks.
So don't do it.
Um,
is that you've got to explain to him what,
what you want.
And you do that through shaping and reinforcing.
And so the transverse is now we go out,
we pick a different drill,
um,
and we come back in and now you have a clicker.
Um,
with humans you can say,
hey,
the click means that that it's good with dogs.
Obviously you have to pair something to it,
but you click and a treat.
Yeah.
You know,
you could click and give them a jelly bean or whatever.
But uh,
so now you come in and,
and the,
the only,
um,
absence of that is when he met.
Like if,
if he grabs the sharpie now and that's not part of the drill,
nothing happens very quickly.
The dog will do what's,
what's called,
learns through self discovery and they start to offer behaviors.
You probably see it in,
in your dog sometimes when they just start doing stuff looking at you.
If you have something and they start doing arbitrary movements,
they're trying to figure out what it's going to take for them to do to get what
they want that you have.
And so now you wait.
And once that,
once he grabs what what you want,
you mark it.
And so now he's like,
okay,
well it's something with this and now it's fun.
It's a game.
And he's trying to figure out,
his mind's working as positive.
Everybody's having fun.
The first example,
it sucks,
you know,
it,
it's painful,
it's stressful.
Uh,
there's cortisol,
it's chaotic.
And again,
that dog's a plus B equals c and you say the percentage of success is the first
method is zero.
Zero.
I have not ever done that and I've done it.
God knows how many times I have never done that experiment where somebody
successfully perform that task.
Not One time,
uh,
on the transverse.
I'd say the only time we're where they haven't been successful is due to
brevity,
is that it's taking longer.
But they,
they either get really close or they finish it.
Uh,
and everybody's laughing,
you know,
cause you know,
the whole rest of the class is watching and,
and uh,
do,
they're usually laughing during the,
the Colorado,
you know,
but,
but it,
it,
it paints a very clear picture because a lot of times people that have not put
their self in a dog shoes.
Again,
just like with leadership is you gotta relate.
You got to understand how it's gonna impact people.
When you're implementing different protocols or procedures or leadership
principles,
what does that look like on the other side?
You know,
it doesn't matter if it makes sense to me.
It doesn't matter if it,
if it seems sound to me,
if they view it as like,
well,
this is crap.
It's unfair.
It's whatever it may be.
But you've got to,
you've got to figure out how to manipulate it so that they understand a,
what the expectations are,
be what the consequences are,
and then see ultimately what,
what comes from both of those depending on what they choose to do.
And that's,
to me,
that's the beauty of operant conditioning with,
with dog training is that you're,
you're letting the dog dictate the consequence and no different than with any of
us.
It,
they enjoy it,
you know,
and it stimulates their mind which they need,
which is another benefit to bonding and relationship with them is because if
you're the one stimulating their mind,
guess what?
Now they want to hang out with you more.
They will listen to you more.
Your,
your blue chip bank just gets overloaded because they've had so many positive
experiences where they've had different things that it's desirable on your end.
That doesn't mean anything to them,
but they're just trying things out and now they do it and it gets marked and
rewarding and it's fun.
It's a game and it's just,
it's a,
it's a self replicating process that a,
that has a ton of benefits for you,
for you and the dog.
I thought this part was interesting.
You're just,
and it's important to know as well to understand dogs a little bit better.
Um,
a dog's sense of smell is somewhere between 10,000 and a hundred thousand
thousand times as sensitive as our own.
There's a PBS television show,
Nova where a guy named James Walker,
and this is a quote from the book,
he said,
if you make the analogy to vision what you and I can see at a third of a mile,
a dog could see more than 3000 miles away.
And there's another example,
Alexandra Horowitz,
the author of inside a dog did something similar but kept the comparison in the
olfactory realm.
You can tell when your coffee has tea or sugar in it.
By taking a sip of it,
a dog could sense that same teaspoon of sugar diluted in a million gallons of
water just by using these nos.
That's insane.
Yeah.
Well,
and from a,
so there's two reasons why that's important.
On the working dog side,
it's,
it's pretty,
uh,
it's pretty clear to see the benefits that,
that,
that has in terms of,
uh,
you know,
sniffing explosives that are buried and a detecting people that are hidden in
false floors and tracking people and things of that nature.
Um,
on the,
on the pet dog side,
where that comes into play is that,
is that same,
um,
you know,
from a relationship is that they recognize you by the way you smell.
Uh,
they recognize your kids by the way they smell in terms of,
of training,
interacting with them,
using treats,
rewards,
toys,
things of that nature.
At a,
you know,
it,
it plays big,
big dividends or,
or pays big dividends too.
So it's just one more component that,
you know,
the,
the reason that the,
that the book is called the navy seal way.
And I,
if there's one thing I could say that I wish I had done a better job with a,
was kind of relaxing.
Why,
why that is,
is that,
you know,
when I think about our reputation and our efficacy and success as a community
since its inception,
uh,
why is that?
You know,
and,
and it's,
it's everything that's in this book just related to dogs.
It's,
well,
it comes by selection,
you know,
have,
have a very stringent selection process.
But then above and beyond that,
you know,
seals don't have the success and reputation because,
um,
because they're good shots or in good shape or have great intelligence or have
some of the best platforms and,
and augments in terms of close air support,
Isr,
whatever,
it's because they have all of those things,
you know,
it,
it's,
it's managing the,
the every single intangible that you can possibly manipulate and control and
stack that deck in your favor.
So it's not just training,
it's not just selecting the right dog,
it's not just feeding them good food.
It's not just keeping them in good physical condition and an ideal body weight.
It's not any one component of that.
It's all of them.
Uh,
and so that the navy seal way,
it's,
it's more about us on a,
on a,
on a big scale in terms of how we've gotten to where we've gotten in by using
all of those same,
same concepts,
you know,
and,
and I used all of those same concepts as a trainer in terms of my selection
processes is godawful.
Um,
you know,
there's times where we would go on,
on,
on trips to,
to feel fine dogs.
And,
and,
and since then even were,
you know,
I may look at dozens or even hundreds of them to find one,
um,
you know,
some,
I would say probably attrition rates are even even worse than,
than buds.
You know,
I mean,
you may have a fraction of a percentage.
We're in the single digit percentage of dogs that I look at that actually end up
making it.
So,
um,
you know,
but it's,
it's that crux of a,
and again,
same,
same with business.
It's like,
it's not just having good accounting,
it's not just having good leadership.
It's not good just having good recruiting.
It's not just having good budgeting and funding.
It's,
it's all of those things.
And when you manipulate the environment and stack the deck in your favor and
make things very consistent and black and white have a,
an ideal ma,
um,
have an idea in your mind of what that finished product is and be able to
visualize that,
know where you're at,
develop a plan and execute it again.
It just goes back to the,
uh,
the microcosm that dog training is that a,
that,
that mimics life,
that talk about this thing and the,
in the book you talk about,
look for the intelligence behind a mistake.
What do you mean by that?
So I found that pretty cool.
Yeah.
So the,
you know,
the intelligence behind the mistake is,
is essentially a teaching moment know,
is that,
understand why it was made.
Ultimately it's,
it's you as the handlers fault for why mistakes are made,
but,
but understand why the dog made the mistake,
you know,
and it could be,
it's,
it's generally gonna going to be reduced down to lack of communication on your
part.
Uh,
a confusion of expectations on the dog's barking with humans.
Same with humans.
Yeah.
Um,
and then,
and then the last thing,
which is probably one of the most imperative things,
uh,
same with humans is,
is bringing emotion into the,
the equation.
Uh,
dogs are,
while they have some simple emotions that mimic humans,
they're nowhere near as complex.
One of the jokes I started a lot of my speeches out with is going to find out
who loves you more,
your,
your spouse or your dog lock.
Both of them in the trunk of your car for two hours after two hours can pop the
trunk.
Who's happier to see it and uh,
you know,
dog and be like,
hey buddy,
where are you Ben?
You know,
your life's going to slap the hell out of here.
So,
uh,
but they are that simple,
you know,
and it's,
it's an Achilles heel of sorts.
We were talking about it before we came on,
came on air as the iPhone,
you know that that's really,
dog dogs are actually so simple that,
that we as humans,
because we're so much more complicated and how we think and emotionally charged
and what have you,
that we make them way more complicated and harder to train than they actually
are.
A,
it's a,
we need to over simplify it.
And to me,
not to get too far off on a tangent,
but the,
it's,
it's Kinda like world world policy,
you know,
foreign policy from a,
from an international standpoint is that sometimes the simplest solutions are
the best for the most complex problems.
You know,
foreign policy being a bar fight,
you know,
uh,
if,
if you're going to go walk into that bar,
you're going to get in a fight,
you know,
and you better bring everything to bear to make sure that you're safe,
but realize that by walking in there,
no matter whose side you take,
no matter what happens,
you're going to create at least one enemy,
probably several,
you know,
so you better make damn sure that going into that bar is worth going into before
you go into it.
To me,
that's a pretty simple solution as a simple way to look at,
at the world's problems.
We don't do that,
you know,
uh,
we overcomplicate it.
But it's that same same mentality with a dog though is,
is that,
uh,
you know,
most times it's the most simple solution to what you think or perceive as the
most complex problem.
And it's really not that complicated.
Yeah.
You talk about,
you,
you go through a whole section that's about reading your dog and,
and what signals to look for.
And it's the same thing with people.
You don't get to learn how to read people,
but you talk about their eyes,
you talk about their ears,
what their ears are doing,
your talk about what their tail,
and this is,
these are all things you told me when I was getting my dog is you know,
things to look for.
And Man,
they were spot on just just looking at their posture.
Interestingly,
we just had Jordan Peterson on and we talked a lot about posture.
He's got a new book out called 1212 rules for life.
And the first chapter,
this is how to live your life.
The first chapter is stand up straight with your shoulders back.
And it's like,
yeah.
And you can see that in dogs and you can see that,
you know,
in the way that you stand around your dog.
You've already talked about that a bunch of today,
but um,
just to,
just to make sure that you have good posture as like simple as that might sound.
And what do you look for in the posture of a doc?
So this is where it,
it depends on what the,
um,
what you're looking for,
what the end goal is.
You know,
if I'm looking for a pet than I probably don't want a cocky scorpion tail ears
up,
chest out looking like King Kong and like he owns the place for a good strong
working god.
Yeah.
I want a dog that's going to make,
make my backend pucker by grabbing Aleisha and open and his gait and clipping it
to it.
Like this dog is making me a little nervous cause he's walking around and
looking at me like,
I don't sweat you as one of the biggest misconceptions is growling.
Um,
you know,
people think,
grilling,
grilling is weakness.
Grilling is,
is being scared and it's peacock feathers essentially.
It's a,
it's a dog's way of saying you're making me uncomfortable.
I'm going to do this.
And in hopes that it makes you,
you know,
it calls your bluff and backs you down.
Um,
when I see a dog growls,
I know I can get in his head faster than a dog is standing there looking at me
with his tail,
just feather and a little bit with his eyes pinpoint and die,
you know,
non non dilated pupils and,
and looking at me like,
dude,
bring it and uh,
you know,
that's the dog I worry about.
Not the dog growl and with his,
with his hair up and his ears back and his in his lips curled,
you know that dog.
I know I can run him if,
if need be,
but um,
it's just a matter of of grabbing a hold of yourself and saying,
let's,
we're going to do the man dance and I'm coming after you.
And 99 times out of 100 and a dog doesn't want anything to do with it,
but you know,
for,
for a pet,
you know,
again,
it depends on,
you know,
my active,
do I want a dog that's going to play a deterrent role in terms of protection and
you know,
do I just want an active companion?
Do I want a docile dog that,
you know,
my kids can snuggle with?
You know,
so to me,
again,
just like with the,
uh,
kind of the,
the,
the macrocosm of,
you know,
what,
what do you want out of the dog?
You know,
let that drive your decision and work backwards from there.
But,
um,
but the,
I think
key point is here,
know that there's traits or visual clues that you can look for that indicate
what kind of a dog,
what kind of personality of the dog has.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And if you don't know those and you just go to a random place and you pick the
dog that came up to you fastest and was wiggling,
or the dog that was all shy and it looks so cute in the corner,
there's consequences to getting those dogs.
And they are,
they're all over the place.
And if you don't know what you're getting,
you're wrong.
Yeah.
Well,
and you know the conversation that we had before you best selected years,
you know,
the,
you hear a lot of things people say,
Oh,
turn the dog up upside down or put them on his back and see if he's calling.
You know,
and there's people that,
you know,
if he's calling,
that's the one you on.
If he's active,
that's the one you went to me.
It's all,
it's all crap.
Honestly.
Um,
what I like to do is,
is just like in,
in any other selection process,
I want to take the dog out of his comfort zone and see now,
see how he,
how he reacts is comfort zone is where he's been raised,
where he's been living with his litter mates,
with his,
his mom.
Uh,
you know,
if you go to a breeder's house and you evaluate a puppy with the,
the litter running around and the mom's standing there,
you are not getting an accurate representation of what that dog's genetic
components are.
Not even close there.
There are so many things that have been smoked in,
mirrored,
uh,
in,
in the dog's benefit.
He's going to look much stronger and better and,
and active and drive your and dominant and whatever then.
Then he truly is,
if you want to really see that dog at his genetic face value,
take him somewhere where,
you know,
he hasn't been by himself.
You told me Home Depot,
which I think is a great cause.
There's things going on at home.
Tons of stuff.
There's noises.
Yeah.
There's a bunch of people running around.
There's other dogs in there.
There's kids,
there's all kinds of chaos going on.
Yeah.
Home Depot.
I mean you'll,
you'll find out about a dog's environmental nerve faster than anything there,
you know,
um,
and so,
but it can be anywhere busy.
It can be a parking lot.
It could be Walmart,
it could be an airport.
I mean wherever you can find that home depot is going to get flooded with.
Yes.
By the way,
just Fyi.
Test dogs like the little puppies.
They're not potty trained yet,
so Fyi for everyone here.
Here's a cool story you put in here.
Back to the book.
Carlos came to my care several years ago.
He was seven years old at the time,
but he had had to retire from the teams during an operation in Iraq on a raid
that resulted in an intense firefight.
He and his handler approach to building suspected of housing cashed munitions
just shorter the entryway or remotely detonated id through the pair back several
yards.
Carlos broke his back and his hind legs and hips and collapsed his sinuses and
his lungs.
For privacy reasons,
I can't go to the injuries his handler sustained other than to say that they
were extensive.
Medical personnel acted quickly and both the dog and the handler survived.
Carlos nearly prevented that emergency treatment from being initiated.
Despite the severity of a of his injuries.
He crawled to his handlers side and took up a defensive perimeter near his
fallen comrade.
No one trained Carlos to do that.
He did it for one reason.
Loyalty.
And you know,
that can't be taught,
you know,
just like it can't be in,
in people.
It can be reinforced.
Uh,
you know,
it can be conditioned,
tweaked a little bit,
one way or another.
It can be broken for sure.
Uh,
but that,
that is a,
in my opinion,
a primal,
a genetically inherited trait that either exists or it doesn't just like with
heart,
um,
you know,
and that's,
uh,
that's something that's excrutiatingly rare,
obviously both in humans and dogs.
And that's one of the,
one of the ways I tested dog is,
is that as I want to test her heart and,
and see if,
uh,
if when push comes to shove,
if they,
if they want to fight me,
you know,
and,
and Carlos was,
was a warrior of,
of a,
the highest magnitude,
no doubt about it.
Um,
you know,
he spent several years with us and then ended up,
uh,
I retired him to a f a dog friend of mine in Florida that had him for a little
while.
And the last picture I got,
um,
got of him was,
uh,
watching the Superbowl laying on a leather couch with a Kong in his mouth.
Got a couple of weeks before he died.
He got,
got the full spectrum,
the got the full retirement,
good deal.
You know,
a dog's possessed here.
Back to the book.
Darks possessed about capability to be loyal,
capability to be loyal.
A dog owner.
As a dog owner,
you should not take that loyalty for granted or exploited.
You should work to give your dog a reason to be the most loyal to you.
He can possibly be.
I mean,
does that not go 100% with human beings as well?
It's,
it's,
you know,
let your dog know that he can trust you.
Yeah.
Be a leader.
Make sure people know that they can trust you.
I mean,
come on,
here's another interesting little story you got in here.
So you've got a guy,
Bob,
who whenever he's working on his car,
he loses his temper,
goes crazy,
throws to us around.
He doesn't know why his dog doesn't like it.
Uh,
back to the book when Bob lost his cool.
Even though Bob didn't direct any of his anger at his dog,
Rudy,
the dog wanted no part of that scenario.
Maybe where he was more sensitive to those kinds of responses than other dogs
might've been.
But Rudy basically lost respect for Bob.
Bob was the guy he expected to be in command and in control,
and he wasn't.
What made things worse for Bob was that he knew that was the case.
So,
so I,
the reason I pulled that one out is because,
again,
I talked about all the time,
Hey,
if you lose your,
if you lose your temper as a leader,
you're,
you're weak.
You're,
you're going to look weak,
you're gonna appear to be weak.
And,
and some people can't control their temper and that's just wrong.
But even a dog,
even a dog will look at a leader that loses his temper and go,
okay,
I can't,
am I following you?
Let's me.
I would say not,
not so much even a dog.
I would say a specialist again.
Well,
there you go.
Because it's,
you know,
I can't,
I can't talk to my dog and say,
hey,
sorry about that.
I lost my cool,
it's not going to happen again.
You know,
I'm still your boss,
but,
uh,
you know,
let's let me make it up to you,
whatever.
Not that that's how you'd approach it anyway,
but,
but my point is,
is that,
you know,
you,
you have that,
that a plus B equals c,
uh,
principle in everything.
You know,
it's whether it's shaping behavior that you desire,
it's,
uh,
eliminating,
undesirable problem behaviors that you've inadvertently created.
It's a,
you know,
breaking,
breaking trust and,
and ruining relationships.
You know,
one of the things that I like to tell people,
uh,
and again,
it's with,
with,
you know,
human relationships also is it trust is like a piece of paper.
Uh,
and when,
when you break it,
it's crumpling it up into a ball.
You know,
you,
you can flatten it back out.
You can iron it,
you can get it real close,
but it will never be the same.
You know,
if,
if you truly break it,
you know,
the way that a lot of people do,
um,
be careful with that,
you know,
cause you only get one crack at ruining it and then,
uh,
and then you're,
you're faced with an uphill battle.
The nice thing with dogs were there were more forgiving and,
and pliable mentally than,
uh,
than our human.
Yeah.
Put them in the trunk of the car for a couple hours and you're still out,
right?
Yeah.
Yup.
Then you've,
the transverse of that as it is if you show your dog that you're unflappable
when you consistently project an image of authority than your dog will
understanding and count on you.
So,
so don't lose your temper and don't do that as a leader either.
Here's another one that you throw in rewards.
Like corrections should be proportional.
The surest way to reduce the effectiveness of a reward is to overuse.
And that's
obviously true with people as well.
First of all,
if you're,
if you're not just with your punishment and somebody makes a small mistake and
you can hammer them destructively that's not helping you.
And at the same time,
if everything that they do good,
you're jumping up and down like a cheerleader,
that's not going to do you any good either.
And same with the dog.
Sure.
And uh,
you know,
the,
the other thing that the varying the reward schedule,
um,
and also there's,
you were echos all into variable rewards.
Yeah.
Right.
Isn't there some kind of,
well there's this psychological hundred percent what the,
with dogs,
it's an,
it's an excuse you told me about something with,
with iPhones though.
Yeah.
Like you're looking for the little thing to pop up and you think maybe this is
the message from,
from whoever the president,
this is,
could be the one could be the one instead,
it's just an advertisement for something sometimes.
But one day it is a message from the president,
but that keeps you in the game during the game.
How many of those have you done?
Yeah.
So you use variable rewards with the dogs.
So with,
uh,
with training it's kind of,
again,
it just falls into a cumulative process.
At first.
It's every time,
you know,
so that there's the consistencies that,
so that,
that,
that's the explanation of the expectation is that you do this,
you get that,
you do this,
you get that until now it's,
it's wired.
Once it's wired now it becomes just like if every time they pick anything,
pick anything you like,
you know,
every Friday we're having steak and ice cream.
Like after awhile it's like no stake in ice cream again.
So that,
that dog will get to a point where now it's actually,
we're not having stake in ice cream and having Tofu burgers joke's on you.
He's like,
wait,
what?
You know,
so now whatever it took that week to get steak in ice cream on Friday,
maybe I'm going to work a little harder and you'll see that out of them.
And so,
and this is more on the,
on the competitive side,
but you know,
when you're judged on,
on flashiness and precision and speed of execution,
when it comes to different behavioral components of obedience,
routines and people want to speed those up and make them more laser like in
their precision,
that's a very effective way to do it.
Is it now,
sometimes you get it,
sometimes you don't.
And so now the dog is,
it's the lottery mentality of doing scratch offs,
you know,
I mean,
nobody wins the powerball,
but the scratch offs,
it's like,
ah,
you know,
made 12 bucks.
Yeah.
You know,
I can almost by what I just spent on him,
I almost got my money back on by them again.
But,
but we're,
you know,
human beings are wired that same way.
How many people waste their money on scratch offs?
A bunch of them for that same reason.
It's,
it's a,
it's a psychological aspect that a,
that actually is very powerful and a dog.
But the caveat to that is that,
you know,
make sure that it's,
it's an ingrained,
conditioned response before you start doing that.
Um,
but yeah,
it is powerful in terms of the flooding.
Um,
when I,
when I'm bridging certain things together,
like if I want to go from,
you know,
I'll teach a dog to recall,
which has come to me first when I'm teaching him to get his backend into his
shoulder hits,
my knee's starting at kind of a healing position in the sitting position.
That's one component.
Then actually walking
off and starting to heal when I want to bridge all of that together.
So,
you know,
if I just give him the,
the,
what I call it plots command,
which is Dutch for place,
is it the dog?
You know,
it,
it does all of that,
you know,
he comes here,
he gets into the plots and then we,
and then we heal off basically when,
when I bridge certain things together,
if I've been building a couple of different components,
then when,
when it clicks the very first time,
I'll flood five,
six,
seven rewards all,
all right at,
at,
at once.
So that he's like,
oh,
paydays and Jack Jackpot.
Uh,
and again,
so it's,
it's kind of a,
almost a successive approximation in terms of,
you know,
teaching different,
different steps,
no different than in Jujitsu and different elements of a move or whatever.
And then once it's paired altogether,
now they get the tap out and they're like,
sweet,
you know,
same,
same type of type of thing.
Yes.
Dig,
dig,
dig.
Uh,
back to the book.
Beware that your dog has no concept of what words mean.
In other words,
if you repeatedly say that word down as in,
down,
your dog will associate that more link free expression as is cute or lie down.
Keep it simple and clear.
Simple,
clear,
concise language.
I did that.
You talk about in the book I did the Broccoli thing with my,
with my dog,
with my wife,
and she was all shocked,
you know,
because I was like,
Hey,
your dog,
you know,
even though you think your dog knows what you're saying,
he actually has no idea.
And then when you talk about in the book,
and I did with my dog,
uh,
yesterday,
I said,
Hey,
our dog has no idea what he's,
what we're saying,
which is,
what do you mean?
I said,
he doesn't know what sit means.
She said,
what do you mean?
I said,
watch this.
And so I gave him to come.
He came over and I said,
Broccoli.
And he sat right down,
just like I said it.
And she was all looking at all confused and I said,
yeah,
that's right.
These dogs don't know what,
but it's the body language and it's the expectations and whatever little subtle
cues I have when I want him to sit,
I did it and I just,
the word came out of my mouth.
It was Broccoli context,
100%.
What dogs are,
you know,
the,
the beauty of dogs is,
is how powerful context,
the Achilles heel is also context for that same reason.
But,
um,
yeah,
it's,
uh,
it's important to,
to make that distinction.
And that's where,
uh,
you know,
using,
using that shaping of behavior is your best friend in terms of,
uh,
you know,
like I said,
I use a classroom,
you know,
there's a reason why libraries and classrooms are the environments that they
are.
So when we teach our kids what we want them to know,
it's a distraction free environment.
You know,
the positive learning experience.
It's a,
it's a petri dish for education,
uh,
when,
when you try to do things where,
you know,
the dog is in the house and doing all these other things,
um,
you know,
there's all these other stimuli going on and it's distracting and the dog's not
picking it up and it's not building that context.
So I use a 40 by 40 training classroom.
It's just a,
it's a fenced in area with nothing in it.
And we go in there and I just stand there and wait for him to start doing stuff.
And then I mark it and reward it and shape it.
And then from there I start to shape a little micro nuanced.
You know,
the dog just turns his head.
Well,
you know,
a fraction of a degree,
one,
uh,
one direction I marked that and rewarded.
If I'm trying to teach a place command,
he looks at the bed,
I marketing roared,
he takes one step.
I'm mark and reward and I just build on that over and over and over.
And the neat thing is once they,
dogs kind of have to learn how to learn.
That way you'll see that light bulb go on.
As soon as they understand,
okay,
you have what I want and I have to earn it,
I have to figure out what it's going to take to get it.
And they start to offer these raw offered behaviors through self discovery then
then that is when you own their mind and you can teach them anything.
Uh,
and that's one of the first things I teach is,
is a place command for that.
That simple reason alone is that it's so powerful and a dog,
if he can look at me and he goes,
dude has what I want and I have to actually go away from it to get it then,
then it's,
it's on
each step.
And I know this question's going to get asked all the time.
Uh,
but you put it in here.
Not only is it possible to teach your dogs to perform tricks,
but I believe you should regardless of the dog's age.
So you can in fact teach an old dog new tricks,
which is a everybody's question.
Yeah.
Everyone old.
What about puppy?
Yeah.
Do you,
do you fill up the hard drive at some point where they can't learn anything new
without forgetting something else?
Not anymore than any of us.
You know,
they,
they can learn.
They can,
they can,
we'll continue to learn.
And to me,
one of the reasons dogs as with people expire earlier than they probably need to
is because of lack of,
of that stimulation,
that mental stimulation.
Um,
you know,
even if the mind or even if the body can't,
can't perform,
there's a lot of other ways that you can get dogs to stimulate their mind and,
and keep them,
uh,
the younger and healthier and happier than,
than just letting them expire on a dog bed.
You know,
five feet away from you
letting your heart get too much in the way of your head and what's best for your
dog will end up causing that heart more pain in the long run.
Discipline equals freedom.
Amen.
Right.
I've been with you have an undisciplined dog,
that dog's going to be miserable.
You're going to be miserable.
Everything sucks.
Yeah,
pretty much.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean it's uh,
like I said,
I mean the,
the,
that's one of my big goals moving into this year is,
um,
is basically starting like a shelter campaign of signing up for the online
training,
saving a dog and,
and uh,
we're going to be launching it here real soon.
But,
um,
you know,
I,
I firmly believe,
you know,
whether you want to call it a calling or whatever is that,
my goal is to,
is to revolutionize how your average everyday dog owner views communicates with
and interacts with her
dog.
Because how many dogs a year gets sent to the pound?
3.3 million dogs every year get surrendered to shelters across this country.
And it varies year to year,
but usually between six and 680 and 750,000 dogs a year get euthanized.
That's over 2000 dogs every day getting put to sleep in this country.
Even at those numbers,
you know,
and it's,
it's not as bad as it as it was,
but it's still astronomically high.
And the way I look at it very simply as it,
you know,
shelters,
God bless him,
um,
are great,
great resources.
We as Americans,
very charitable.
Uh,
I've opened up our hearts and wallets and,
and provided pretty astounding resources for animals,
whether it's ASP c,
h,
s,
u,
whatever,
shelters,
rescue organizations,
you name it.
But to me,
it's,
it's no different than throwing money at the symptom.
You know,
it's not addressing the problem.
the problem is why are they getting there in the first place?
Because with 83 million dogs out there,
uh,
you can't have enough resources to,
to accommodate that,
you know?
And so it's,
it's like,
uh,
it's like the,
the pharmaceutical industry,
you know,
it's,
it's dealing with the symptoms and not trying to fix,
fix the problem,
you know,
and,
uh,
of course there is potentially some politics involved with that in terms of
maintaining funding and salaries and jobs.
I get all that,
but,
uh,
to me,
shelters,
number one goal should be to have zero dogs in it.
Um,
you know,
if,
if you're not,
if that's not your goal,
you're wrong and I'll,
I'll,
I'll call any one of them out.
Uh,
right now.
you know,
your goal should be to be out of a job in,
in my opinion.
You know,
and,
and to me,
that starts with,
um,
with teaching people how to communicate with their dogs.
And it's everything that we've talked about,
but,
uh,
it's,
it's really not that complicated.
Um,
you know,
and,
and the,
the gratification you get from doing it yourself and the understanding of your
dog and it,
it transcends just that,
you know,
just like,
with what you,
what you do.
Um,
you know,
you can take all of these same lessons and apply them to your kids,
to your spouse,
to your business partners,
to your employees,
whatever.
Um,
and,
and it all works the same way.
Yeah.
We're going to close out the book.
I'm just gonna run through these fundamental principles you have.
And as I'm saying them,
think about not just dogs,
but everyone that doesn't have a dog.
Think about people,
anyone that's in a leadership position.
Think about leading those people as it applies.
Docs.
One,
look at things from the dog's perspective.
How often does it we get a somebody that works for us and we don't think about
what's going through their brain and why,
what we're saying,
how,
what we're saying to them or how,
what we're making them do impacts them.
Appreciate the differences in how dogs use their senses to perceive the world.
Same thing.
Think about the people that you've got working for.
You.
Look at the intelligence behind the mistake.
You already,
you already talked about that reward,
good behavior.
Uh,
Duh.
But how often do we not do that as a leader?
Punish or extinguish bad behavior.
Duh.
Again,
but how often do we let little things slide?
We just,
if you're letting things slide,
if somebody wants to be late day after day,
oh that's okay.
We're saying it's okay.
Next be consistent in the application of awards and punishment.
Well,
there you go.
This is especially true with kids.
If you're not consistent with the kids,
like they don't learn.
And,
and I think opposite of dogs actually a kid,
if they think they can get away with it once,
like a variable reward,
variable punishment,
they think they're going to gamble there.
They can get away with it.
Again,
dogs,
all dogs,
we'll test the water
on your pretty hard that way too.
A lot of them are more,
more intuitive and sharp than you think.
But uh,
um,
keep emotion out of the,
of an evaluation of good and bad and the application of punishment.
This is super smart if,
especially with kids and with employees and with dogs.
But if you're punishing the people or your workers or your employees or your
dogs out of anger,
you're,
you're not doing a good job.
You're not doing a good job.
In fact,
just Fyi,
when I have to do punishment with my kids,
I do it in like the most cold blooded serial murderer kind of way that I can the
bloods instructor as if this isn't completely emotionless as like,
well,
you know,
unfortunately I have to do this because if your behavior,
so go ahead and report to the garage,
you know,
so they're going to get,
they're going to get hammered,
but I think that's better.
Oh,
it's far more impactful,
you know?
I mean think about above the instructor,
like none of them really scream at you.
Yeah.
That's the,
that's the,
the antithesis of the,
of the Marine Corps Dai.
Like it's just white noise at that point.
Just standing there like,
yeah,
whatever.
When that dude's like whispering,
like I'm going gonna I'm going to snatch the life out of your soul,
crushing right in front of your face.
And the kids are like 18 years old,
blown his anal glands like Jesus,
what did I sign up for a next,
understand how dogs communicate overwhelmingly through body language and use
that understanding and method of communication back to them to elicit the kinds
of behaviors we want.
And we,
we,
we talked about this before on the podcast and know you've probably heard this
before,
but they say humans,
humans communicate,
even though we're all verbal and all that,
it's an 80% is nonverbal.
80% is nonverbal.
But this is,
I don't know,
probably someone will say,
no,
it's not 80,
it's 78,
but it's a huge percentage is nonverbal.
Well,
to me,
to me where I think,
uh,
you know,
not to get too off track,
but we're,
where the disparity is,
is that in with technology,
so much of our communication doesn't involve interaction,
right.
You know,
it's emails,
it's text messages,
even it's phone calls,
whatever,
you know.
So I think in person maybe,
um,
you know,
but because there's such that so watered down by,
by everything,
you know,
people do this.
I mean,
I've been working with businesses all the time.
We,
I uncover all kinds of people that have all kinds of problems because they're
only communicating through email or through text and therefore the people aren't
picking up on all those other signals that we have relationships that get
destroyed.
Because,
you know,
I made a joke to you about something and it was in a text message and,
and I didn't put a lol
Emoji after it.
So you didn't think I was joking and all of a sudden we got an issue.
So this is definitely something that we have to remember.
That's why I have like a rule in emails.
I don't joke around in emails like I don't,
I don't know,
make jokes in emails unless I just completely,
if we know each other and we,
we can get,
we get there,
but I'm not joking around,
you know,
if I have a client,
I'm not saying,
uh,
you know,
I'll be there in a few weeks and hopefully I'll be able to your ass out there.
They're like,
wait,
wait a second.
Even though I'd be kidding.
But they don't know that through the email,
back to the book,
determine our needs and understand how a dog's prey drive energy level and other
physical traits contribute to a matrix of behavior.
What does that say?
No.
Your people know your people.
What's driving them?
What are they motivated by?
What's going to make them work harder?
Next,
provide a dog with ample amounts of exercise and interaction with other dogs and
people in a multitude of different environments.
What I liked about that is the APP,
the obviously exercise interaction,
multiple of different environments.
This is where I see people that are in a training capacity.
They train people only in one environment and so they get outside of that
environment.
They fall apart,
feed him a diet with maximum health benefits within our means.
Hey,
right.
Eat good food.
Steak.
Yeah.
Basically we know,
we all know what we're referring to.
I brought home some of my Bros gave me a uh,
cow femur the other day.
I brought it home for my dog.
Just a raw cow.
Femur.
You want to talk about a pumped up dog?
Rock and roll.
He's still just getting after that thing.
That's what nature intended
before.
Undergoing formal training.
Develop a bond of mutual trust and respect,
so get that relationship going before you demand a bunch of stuff from people.
Become the authority figure in a dog's life that he wants a needs.
Take the time to be patient.
Do multiple repetitions,
building different levels of distraction and employee variable reward schedules,
all to ensure that a concept is firmly embedded in dogs mind.
Now we'll talk a little bit about Jujitsu here.
You got to do the repetition and then you've got to do it in different,
you know,
you,
you gotta,
you gotta arm lock.
You got to try an arm lock live rolling a hundred times before you get one,
at least a hundred maybe more.
And in order to shorten that time,
you got to do more drills and then you can shorten that time from a hundred
maybe you only got to do it at 44 times before it works.
You think about when you learn a new move in Jujitsu,
it can take a long time.
The better.
You understand it in the isolated training environment,
the quicker you gonna be able to do it live
well.
And from a behavioral standpoint,
it's the same thing.
Like teach it in that sterile classroom and then move it into the living
environment and going out for walks,
going past dog parks,
you know,
busy.
Yup.
Playgrounds,
whatever is it,
you know,
people are like,
yeah,
he's doing great in the classroom.
And then I take him to the park and he just loses his mind.
Like,
where did you bridge that?
You can't go from third grade to to,
you know,
a sophomore in college and that's what you're doing.
Like you're,
you're not,
you're missed.
You missed about 15 steps in between there,
you know.
So my dog was distracted in Walmart.
No kidding.
Yeah,
idiot.
Yeah.
Next use.
Good problem solving skills to identify the root cause of a problem and work out
the solution to resolve the issue and not just hide it.
I,
I'll another thing,
you see this in relationships and companies where they just,
everyone is hiding this problem.
No one will address the problem.
No one's going to address the problem.
So if you've got problems,
default aggressive,
get aggressive,
find a solution to the problem and implement it.
That kind of wraps up this book.
I'm like I said,
team dog is the name of the book,
how to train your dog,
the navy seal way
and good stuff in there,
not just for dogs but for humans as well.
And Mike obviously appreciate your service and not only what you did when you
were in the teams,
but everything you've done and did once you got out of the teams.
And thanks for coming on the podcast now.
I know you've got a bunch of things going on right now.
Yeah.
Well first off,
I appreciate you having me on.
It's uh,
it's an honor and uh,
uh,
happy to,
happy to do it.
Um,
yeah,
in terms of everything I have going on,
I mean the,
to me,
the crux of what I would pass on to,
to anybody listening is,
is again,
is,
is the,
is really trying to get to the root core of,
of communicating with your dog.
And,
and you know,
to me,
if,
if nothing else,
let it be an experiment and practice for the rest of your relationships,
you know,
uh,
because it,
it does transpire or transcend rather,
um,
you know,
just,
just training a dog.
But,
um,
the online training just a month by month,
you look,
they can go to team dog.pet,
uh,
to check that out.
It's,
you know,
team dog.cat.
Dot.
That's where you have online training where people can learn to solve these
problems that they have with a dog or build a good relationship with her dog and
train their dog.
Yeah,
just,
it's a monthly lesson.
It's a cumulative process.
It starts out just like everything we talked about,
building the relationship first,
shaping and reinforcing behavior and then working on an extinguishing,
things,
correcting problems,
et cetera.
We're in,
uh,
the,
the halfway through the second year of it.
Um,
and it's,
it's gone.
Gotten some really good feedback.
There's forums that has,
I get on there and I answer questions every Monday,
uh,
with,
with all the,
all the,
the members and the people interact with each other.
And give each other advice and post videos and a bunch of other stuff.
We're going to launch some affiliate partnership programs here with the,
with people getting other people to sign up soon.
But that in conjunction with the book and then launching a Trackos training
franchises,
which are going to augment all of the people out there that are subscribers.
So basically,
you know,
it's working with certified Trackos and team dog trainers all over the country
that have these franchises everywhere,
uh,
that help you go through this monthly training curriculum.
And,
uh,
you know,
the,
the crux of it though is,
you know,
just like with anything,
you need help from some people.
You need guidance with learning Olympic lifts or Jujitsu moves or whatever.
But you mean you have to put the time in yourself.
But this will allow people to,
uh,
you know,
to,
to seek some,
some guidance in person from people if they're having specific issues or
whatever that they're not able to get from the online stuff.
But we've had just overwhelming feed,
positive feedback on success story after success story and know these 65 year
old grandmothers that have their labradoodle out there,
you know,
healing and walking around dog parks and stuff and they're just loving it.
It's been pretty awesome.
But,
um,
so that's,
uh,
that's kind of the big,
big thing.
And He's talks about trike goes,
I don't even know if we talked about Tricoci Cosia trickles.
Is the company that you formed up while you were still in?
No.
Uh,
so this is actually my second dog company,
but,
uh,
formed it a little over five years ago.
Um,
and it's the,
the crux of it is,
is a personal protection.
Dogs,
police,
dogs,
military dogs,
we do sell it,
but for a fair number of dogs to private individuals for,
uh,
you know,
the personal protection aspect.
And that's kind of what it was born and bred out of.
And in conjunction with putting on a lot of police seminars and selling police
dogs and teaching at conferences and stuff like that.
But,
um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
so that's,
that's my for profit company.
If,
if you,
in terms of everything that I have going on in the best place to go is just
[inaudible] dot com that is the resource that talks about the team dog online
stuff,
the Tracko stuff,
the speaking engagements to book for that or uh,
you know,
the franchise stuff coming up or even the warrior dog foundation.
The books that I've written,
it's kind of a,
a landing page of everything that I have going on.
mike.com
and the warrior dog foundation.
Again,
you mentioned a couple times,
but just give a little bit of a,
of a,
of a plug for that too.
People know what it is.
So Warrior Dog Foundation,
uh,
we started it back in August of 2010.
Um,
and we've taken and a little over 80 dogs at this point.
started off with just doing special operations dogs,
be at seal dogs,
rangers,
whatever.
Uh,
and we've taken in a lot of police dogs,
contract working dogs,
military working dogs and uh,
kind of our main,
main goal and function with that is to act as a,
as an indefinite sanctuary for those dogs.
First and foremost when we get 'em in,
we evaluate them.
Some of them we've been able to repurpose,
rehabilitate and get to police departments and you know,
some of them have come in and spend a few months and then we've gotten them back
to back to service,
was working with them and,
and kind of unwinding their mind a little bit using a lot of the same principles
that we've been talking about today.
Um,
but more than anything is that,
you know,
these dogs are at that kind of where their last resort,
they were going to get the blue juice here within days and we step in and take
them and either just,
you know,
continually try to rehabilitate them to where we can either rehome them to a
civilian application or another police department or whatever.
Or we just let them live out their life,
be a dog,
have fun chase balls and run around the woods and,
and hang out and,
and retire and uh,
out to pasture so to speak.
But a warrior dog foundation.org is the website for that if you want to check it
out.
And of course we're,
we're always gracious and appreciative of,
of any support.
If there's someone that listens to this podcast,
it gets all fired up to get a dog.
Um,
obviously get the book,
I'm going to tell you that right now.
Get the books so you can make a good assessment,
make a good judgment.
And um,
think
there's a lot of work to have a dog.
I have four kids,
I've had dogs,
multiple dogs.
When I had a bunch of kids,
we actually didn't have dogs for awhile cause kids and dogs are a lot of work.
If you're not willing to put the work into the dog,
then that's,
you're not going to be a good parent.
Is that the right way?
No,
you're not gonna be a good dog owner.
So I almost,
I almost went sideways there,
so yeah,
you're not,
you're going to be a bad dog.
Daddy.
Yeah.
You're not going to be a good dog owner.
And believe me,
I had to find,
I got three daughters and one son and for the years of me beating them down
saying no dog,
no dog,
no dog.
Because I knew that I couldn't put enough time and effort into it to make it a
dog,
have a good life and the dog be squared away and be disciplined and be able to
protect my family.
So it took a while to get there.
But then finally when my kids were old enough,
you know,
I got one out of the house and now we have a good environment for it.
And so think about that before you run out and buy a dog.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
I mean,
it's a,
it's like with anything,
you know,
um,
don't,
don't do impulse decisions.
Do your due diligence and research and uh,
just like,
you wouldn't just say,
oh,
let's adopt a kid and see what happens.
You know,
don't add,
don't do the same thing with the dog.
Yeah.
I'm bored.
It's Friday night.
Let's go to the,
let's go to the shelter and pick up a new dog.
Not a good call.
All right,
Echo.
Um,
we've learned a lot about how to help dogs and train dogs.
Maybe you could tell us how [inaudible]
we can help ourselves a little bit.
Is it true that no dogs don't have a personality.
They have a dog [inaudible] get it.
Um,
I just meet that are currently,
hey,
but that's okay.
Tucker minute.
I need to work on the operant conditioning with echo ca.
Real flimsy.
Granite shock collar.
Real quick
punishment.
No Man.
Anyway,
good news is Jocko has supplements.
Finally,
when I say finally not like yes,
finally,
like,
cause the whole world is was waiting.
Yeah.
Like for decades.
Kind of.
Can I jump in one quick second before that?
Of course we are launching a a trackos dog supplement line,
uh,
when the next couple of weeks ago.
Speaking of supplements go on trek dot on there for dogs.
I'm not stepping on your toes,
but yeah.
So you know,
check,
check in.
Stepping on my toes at all.
In fact,
I expect a package of my house for my dog.
Hey Man,
get y'all hooked up to,
it's got a button and you just got your advertisement in there.
Yeah.
You're going to pay for that.
What kind of supplements they'll like,
what does it supplement?
Just native.
Yeah.
Starting out.
It's going to be a different oils.
Um,
and then we'll get into college and later this year and stuff like that.
It's all cognitive driven,
you know,
CBD and a different essential oil stuff and joint supplements and stuff like
that.
So it's kind of a kind of a mix of a few different things.
But most of it is,
is for joint pain,
for overall health cognitive function things like,
yeah.
And it all stems
from the warrior dog,
uh,
research that we've done in terms of what works with them in terms of raw foods
and different joint supplements.
And,
and again,
the college is a big thing and uh,
just kind of drawn off of all of our experience with that,
but keep them physically maintained kind of thing.
That's a big component.
You know,
it's like a bunch of broken warriors,
you know,
they take,
take a lot of extra,
a lot of extra care and,
and uh,
an animal husbandry to keep him,
keep him sound echo was using that as a segue.
I could feel it.
Feel it was same thing cause Jocko supplements juggle Super Krill oil for joints
and joint warfare obviously also for joints.
Glucosamine,
conjoint,
curcumin.
Somebody just asked me about what Jujitsu don't your fingers hurt cause you're
with the Geek.
Yeah,
it's,
it's the common answer is yeah,
of course they hurt the joint warfare answer at the Krill oil answers is not too
bad early.
Yeah,
your hands will get like sort like muscle soreness but my finger and then again,
it depends on how much of the g and how much grabbing you do I have a low
d grabbing game.
Yes.
Awkward thing.
It's not that I don't grab the Geek because I certainly do,
but if,
oh,
I grabbed that geek.
But if you are determined,
you get that look in your face.
Like you want me to let go?
You're gee,
guess what I'm going to do.
I'm gonna hold on it for the last millisecond.
And when you pull with all your mind,
I'm gonna let go of it because I'm doing something else.
But yeah,
there's you,
you see a meow brothers using their hands,
they're all jacked up and you've watched their Jujitsu game.
That's why,
cause they're,
they're just,
they will not let go of that.
G they'll get weird positions and it's,
it's going to hurt.
I don't even know if joint warfare would help him out.
I'm going to help out them.
Y'all broke at least a little bit,
but maybe a little bit about your,
you know,
that's the life he chose kind of thing with [inaudible] and yeah,
you have a real low grabbing
medium,
regular g grabbing guy.
Um,
no joint pain,
by the way.
I'm on Krill oil,
Krill oil during warfare.
I think it's going to help regardless.
Yeah,
no,
there are certain people,
if you have it like,
like a surgeons,
we,
we know know people that are surgeons that train Jujitsu.
You cannot have a high geeky commitment.
Grab,
grabbing commitment.
That's really what I'm talking about.
I finally figured it out.
I grabbed the g a lot,
but my commitment on the grabs is relatively low compared to somebody that's all
about all about that.
Like that's 100% committed to g grabbing.
Yeah,
that's true.
To me it's just a setup though.
Like when you're,
when you're decide you're going to get that,
you're going to break my grip.
There's since that's my game,
when you go to break my gear rep,
I know that you're going to break my grip and I have the,
the,
the chain of events are about to occur.
Yeah.
It's kind of like when you're a kid,
when you,
when you're playing with your friend or whatever,
they're like pulling his arm and he's like,
well he's trying to pull it back.
You're pulling in more and more and then you let go on.
You trip is lick any falls back.
Same thing with Jockos g grabbing to set up.
Yeah.
To set up.
None the less.
If your fingers are sore from your geeky grabbing commitment levels.
Super Krill joint warfare.
Mine was the elbows and my back.
Good.
Good to go.
Now also the subscription is now available.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
From what I understand,
coolest cause we have the data,
right?
Everyone talks about the data.
We have the big data on,
on Super Krill,
on joint warfare.
And what's cool is when people buy it,
they buy more,
which is the best indicator I can see because when you try it,
you feel it,
then you want it.
And so people had requested,
we put subscription.
So if you want to subscribe,
just get the Krill delivered to you.
Yeah.
What is that like a monthly?
You can do both.
You can do every two weeks and you can do with that.
We can do it with joint warfare.
You can do it with the discipline case.
You lacking discipline,
you can get it now.
Some people,
that's all they need.
Just a little discipline and boom,
they're good to go.
Speaking of which discipline,
what does discipline?
It's a cognitive physical supplement.
Yeah.
Pre,
pre workup for me.
Pre mission pre-life.
Oh,
it's pre mission.
If you have a mission,
you take the discipline,
it'll help it.
Um,
there's some cognitive stuff in there,
some little bit of caffeine,
right seat.
You little bit fired about 15 milligrams.
Yeah.
Because you go beyond that and I start to feel like how much is one cup of
coffee and it's like 45 or 50 or a no,
I want to say a cup of coffee.
Oh yes.
You,
I think you are right.
I think it's not your standards at 45 or 50.
So you figure 15 third.
Yup.
Something like that.
That's what's in white tea by the way.
There's no coincidence there.
That's a little bit more than I thought.
Not that,
that's a lot.
It's not a lot at all.
Really like 15,
15 or as people don't want to do anybody that's a coffee drinker.
Yeah.
Like drinking a third,
a cup of coffee's not that much.
They're going to want more for sure.
But it's not nothing.
Yeah.
Something.
It's true.
Yeah.
So that's good to me.
That's good.
Um,
nonetheless,
uh,
you know,
you take it before you do some something that requires physical and mental
stuff.
Just like how we were talking about these huge,
it's,
you don't take it before Jujitsu though.
I do take it.
I don't take it before I left.
Right before you work on it.
Yeah,
because I don't,
yeah,
it's early in the morning.
It's just not about that.
I think what you're drinking now,
this is white tea.
I had a drink of,
I had the first drink.
I have watched.
It was the discipline flavored.
It is,
and it actually tastes good because the chocolate is like that.
Yeah.
It needs it to taste really delicious.
Taste.
It does taste good.
I,
oh,
he's,
he's talking about my palate again and,
Oh man,
wait,
wait.
Who I'm talking about you?
Hello,
Mike.
Yeah.
Same thing that happened on Jordan Peterson podcast.
Apparently I have a sensitive Fallon,
what'd you say?
Refined.
Refined,
but not refined.
So yes.
Discipline tastes good.
Legitimately tastes good.
You know what you can do,
and I don't recommend this at night.
Well,
it's a little risky.
It tastes good enough to have for dessert.
It's got a little sweetness to it,
right?
It's got,
if you got a little sweetness you can take,
you can take it for dessert because you think,
oh man,
I just want to like a little,
oh,
boom.
There you go.
You have some discipline but you gotta watch out because if,
unless you have,
I try not to take it if I don't have something to do.
Right.
Yeah.
And if it's eight o'clock sometimes I eat late at night cause I could eat when I
get done training,
if I'm,
I don't want to be taken it that late at night.
But why?
Because the caffeine because the cat,
just the caffeine and there's the whole,
the whole of micro,
the micro dose of caffeine.
So,
but I have last night I did,
cause I'm prepping like 14 podcasts right now.
So I had some discipline late last night so I could dream.
What do you mean dessert though?
So what do you sprinkling it on?
A lemon meringue pie or something like that.
Mix Up.
Mix up a shake.
Oh and you just mentally assign dessert status to it?
It's my dessert now,
although the other day I,
I ate discipline.
You were with me.
Yes sir.
And I was saying it's kind of like doing a shot of,
of of whiskey cause you know,
kind of you do a shot of Whiskey,
you go ha,
yeah.
It was like a pay style or are you just powder?
Right.
A tower.
Rudolph power did it ate the powder like the creatine days.
It tastes better than the way.
Yeah.
So then like the Koolaid just straight up in the day when you make the Koolaid
and let me just get it the look of made.
What's the,
what's the aw man,
I figured I was like about to ask you what that is and I figured out mid
sentence.
Alright.
If or when you do go to buy these things,
you got to origin mean.com.
That's where they are super grill joint warfile warfare discipline.
Get the subscription.
What I'm saying straight up do that sounds like a good goal.
I know that the subscription is available.
That's like,
it's obvious that that's the way to go cause running out isn't good.
No.
By the way,
like when you ran out of Krill oil,
that's what I'm kind of mentally drawing upon and he can tell you guys is um,
very important also at,
or do you mean that.com gs and rash guards.
If you are about that g grabbing commitment and you're going to put on a g in
the event of you wanting to put on a geek or needing to put on a g,
you get an origin.
He all made in America also compression gear,
which is rash guards,
spats approved terminology,
fruit,
which are what,
what's another word for spats?
Let's say I'm just tuning in.
Compression pants.
Pants.
Yeah.
Again,
this is spats got approved because we found out the root meaning.
Yeah.
Um,
nonetheless you get them from origin,
mean.com all made in America.
It's really cool stuff.
Other stuff on their hoodies and whatnot.
Anyway,
just go there.
If he like something,
get something good way to support.
Also if you are into,
and I always say cat,
mainly the kettlebells.
Okay.
On it.
You know they have cattle but you know on it,
right.
You know,
the cool kettlebells did premo bells at the whole set.
By the way I got there,
I got pretty dope.
That's why I got the big,
big foot one than Jocko thinks he's all actually Jocko was salty that it had a
bigger kettlebell than him.
Of course he had to go buy more,
but nonetheless,
I got the whole set kettle bells bigger than your yeah,
I got the whole set or the Caribbean or two of them together and start slinging
them.
Yeah,
I'm sure that's what he was doing for awhile and he was like,
there's go to be a better way to compete with Echo.
Anyway,
there's other stuff on there as well.
Actually,
I do mention this as well.
Maces and um,
there's like these little,
like they're called something Dell.
They're like these little flat kind of leather weights.
Steel bells is what they're called.
Yeah.
Something.
Anyway,
then you want to vary up your workout,
you know,
deviate from the,
the mundane boring workout that you might be doing right now.
Go there and get some cool stuff.
Good way to support.
Also when you buy the books that Jocko reviews and also Mike's book bikes.
Got Three Bucks.
Yeah.
Books.
Should I say team dog,
right?
Yep.
How to train your dog,
the navy seal way also that that came.
Then you said there's two others that were essentially the same book,
the same book,
seal team,
dog,
same deal.
Team dog is the same as this young adult.
Yeah.
Also there's a,
there's training Canon wars and there's navy seal dogs.
Navy seal dogs is trying to canine words,
but it's the Gotcha young and old version.
So yeah.
So when you're going to get that booked and don't worry,
I got you.
Go to Jocko podcast.com and the book section,
it'll be by episode would be all these books and all the other books from other
episodes,
all organized.
Take you to Amazon.
Boom.
You click buy on Amazon prime.
You get the book that same day.
Sometimes.
Sometimes
good way to support if you're going to continue to do it.
Do your other shopping,
you know that lawnmower that you're,
you're on the fence about to buy.
Get that to also subscribe to the podcast.
If you haven't already,
iTunes,
Google,
play,
stitcher,
any anywhere else you listen to podcasts,
just subscribe.
That's a good way to uh,
support.
Leave a review if you're in the mood.
I wouldn't say leave a review if you're not in the mood.
No,
don't.
I've heard people say that like leave a review.
Oh,
no matter what.
No.
Well actually,
you know what,
I'm,
that's not true.
It's fascinating your life and a good sense of humor to leave a funny review.
That's cool.
Do it.
Yeah.
That's strong encouragement.
I don't if you don't have the capacity in your life because some people don't
know it's going to take seven minutes.
Right.
There's going to be misspellings in there.
You really want to post that?
No,
just walk away.
Agree.
Livery view.
Also subscribe to Youtube because we have a youtube channel,
by the way.
Do you have a youtube channel?
I do actually.
Yep.
It's a,
yeah,
you can get there off of micro on Dotcom also.
But yeah.
Um,
yeah,
I still subscribe to your channel mix as well.
You don't remember right now?
I can tell you about 90% on the micro,
on the website.
I didn't put on there.
So,
uh,
I couldn't even tell you what it is.
Yeah.
Just watched a bunch of your videos on that.
I'm sure if you just put in Mike Ritalin.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And you too.
Not to be confused with the other one.
What other ones?
There's not another one.
Here you go.
So gotcha.
Nonetheless,
subscribe.
Uh,
do we,
what do we got?
The vision video version of this podcast and excerpts and deluxe ex or ups.
So we're calling them right now.
Okay.
I'm going to work on for that.
Jackie gave me good pep talk the other day.
Inadvertent,
by the way,
because you weren't unless he was seeing in inadvertent.
But that's the thing with this guy.
Subtle like we're,
he'll give you a pep talk talk and you don't know that it's a peck.
The pep talk at the time.
What's one that sounds more calculated than ever?
Uh,
an advert now that I realized that was calculated a smile at the end.
I'm like leaving the whole,
we drove back from La,
whatever and I'm leaving it and I'm like,
you have no idea.
What am I going to write down,
but to do all this stuff,
I got it all planned out or whatever.
And it's like,
yeah,
I don't think Jocko realized like that.
That really help.
You know what we talked about?
Yeah.
He does know nothing.
Middle last,
share what you talked about
how to just stuff.
I would say this.
Wait and see.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It has something to do with me being reluctant to post certain videos sometimes
like gun shy kind of.
Yeah.
In a way.
Letting let the hands go.
Kinda lift the hands.
Yeah.
Wayne Gretzky quote of you miss 100% of shots you don't take.
There you go.
Yeah.
That was part of the conversation and on the list,
what that has to do is with his video,
so we're gonna,
we're gonna release a little bit more videos,
different types of videos,
but if you like videos in relationship to this podcast in any capacity,
just subscribe to the Youtube Channel.
Also chuck was a store,
if you don't know already,
it's called Jocko store.
[inaudible] DOT com.
This is where you can get chocolate pod,
cast shirts,
discipline equals freedom shirts,
victory MMA shirts,
the one that Jocko where's every single day
and uh,
you know,
some rash guards on there,
some hoodies on there.
Um,
you know,
any kind of gear Jocko,
Jocko gear really is what it is a very good way to support also psychological
warfare.
If you didn't know what that is.
If you're on the path,
we call it the path.
A campaign against weaknesses.
What we've all,
we also called it
and you hit those moments of weakness.
Like you know,
you,
you want to hit the snooze so to speak,
literally and figuratively.
You want to hit the snooze.
Right.
What does hitting the snooze in life?
Just like I can't do it right now.
I'll do it later in life.
Yeah.
Like news button should say,
hit this button and destroy all of your hopes and dreams.
As far as the fun,
I dig it.
It should say that,
but he,
the hitting the what that's like,
what?
Like,
I don't feel like doing it right now.
I'll do it in 10 minutes.
Right.
Can I give you a product?
A recommendation,
a new Jocko product.
What are you got developed on us?
It's a,
it's a snooze button.
Shock collar.
Just shock like it.
Yeah.
Actually you can just,
you know what else you can do is you can hit the snooze button,
you can sleep in and then you can wake up 20 minutes,
half an hour later with that part of your life gone forever with your,
with your schedule now being off with the opportunity to improve yourself
physically and mentally gone,
gone can never get it back.
You can take that feeling,
you can embrace it and then you can just go ahead and next time you see that
snooze button you can get pissed off and get up and get out of bed and get after
it.
Deal.
And you know what,
in a more maybe echo way of thinking about it to the,
you don't even benefit from the five minutes.
No other way.
I,
it makes you more tired.
Yeah.
Cause it's not like you're like,
Dang,
I need the nine minutes of sleep or whatever.
You know?
And then you're like,
you get up.
You're like,
Dang,
that nine minutes really helped me.
It's not like that didn't work.
Like you said,
your worst factually.
So don't hit the snooze button in the event of you needing help,
not hating this news.
He's listened to psychological warfare and this goes for any other little
moment,
a weakness.
Like if you're gonna skip the workout for the day,
we know those.
Yeah.
Wait,
we do.
It's part of life I think.
Nonetheless.
I just got,
I just got my first like mad look for METCO.
I think armor.
No,
no.
You got some before really.
Well,
not a,
not on the Jujitsu match because you've looked at me real mad on the GC.
Genuine,
inc anger,
by the way.
Nonetheless,
he listened to psychological warfare.
It's an album with tracks.
Jocko tracks Jocko telling you why you shouldn't hit this news.
Skip the workout,
eat donuts,
sugar coated,
why you shouldn't procrastinate,
which is a big deal.
It's huge deal.
Actually.
Procrastination I think is worse than hitting the snooze.
Well,
it's the same thing.
It is the same thing that is,
it's a physical and psychological manifestation of procrastination.
Without question.
You could also say procrastinate.
Now go touch this button.
Actually,
in a way it's even worse.
Actually straight up it's even worse because the snooze button at least has like
10 minutes later the alarms coming back on.
See what I'm saying?
Procrastination is an indefinite snooze button and maybe you should call it the
procrastination button.
Yeah,
that's what it's called.
That's what it'd be called on the Jocko alarm
clock.
Yeah.
Boom.
There it is,
but that's what it is.
Like logic worth or for a day,
hey look,
when Jocko tells you in in his terms why you should or shouldn't do things,
it makes sense.
When you just said the Jocko alarm clock,
the re,
one of the reasons why we actually made this was because people kept saying,
oh,
you should make her alarm clock.
Did you make an alarm clock?
Well with this,
with a,
with a psychological warfare album,
you can take those tracks from the album and you can put them as your alarm
clock if you choose to do that.
The big warning is if you're married,
you don't really want to do this too loudly because you're wonderful.
Freak out.
A couple other things.
You can get Jocko white tea,
you can get it on Amazon and if you,
if you're looking to be able to deadlift 8,000 pounds as a minimum,
we have people going above that.
Now if you get Jocko white tea,
it's a guarantee that you'll be able to deadlift 8,000 pounds that's in there
right on the package yesterday.
Yeah,
I mean it's already been approved by the FDA and the CIA and the FBI.
Double,
triple blind people.
Uh,
soccer,
white tea.
You know what straight up tastes awesome.
Makes you feel good.
Books again,
Mike's book tried it.
Canine Warriors,
navy seal dogs,
team,
dog.
Those are all available.
Uh,
and also some books.
I got some books for instance.
What if you wanted your kid to work out,
study,
eat good food,
train Jujitsu,
and be highly disciplined?
What would you,
would you want that for your kid and the answers in there?
Invariably,
yes you would.
So I wrote a book called the way of the warrior kid.
So your kid will start getting in the game,
overcoming fears to and flares.
Forgot about that one.
Overcoming fears,
not being picked on,
making a plan,
following through.
Also,
I just had,
well soon to come out another book.
It's called the way of the warrior kid too.
It's called Mark's mission.
Now we go a little bit further.
What if you wanted your kid to take control of their emotions,
wanted them to learn and understand the value of money and how to earn money and
how to save money.
Wanted your kid to learn about helping other people,
wanted your kid to become a leader,
but if you wanted those things for your kids,
well guess what way the warrior kid to Mark's mission.
It's available right now for preorder on Amazon.
So check that out.
Speaking of warrior kids also,
there's a 12 year old warrior kid named Aiden
and he has a business,
he's a businessman at age 12 he's making soap from goat's milk on his farm.
He wanted to make good soap.
He said,
can I make Jocko soap?
And I said,
do it
Irish oaks ranch.com get some soap from Aden the warrior kid.
And I think I inadvertently made up the slogan for his soap.
It's a simple,
it's a simple,
it's here,
but there's layers.
It's real easy.
Stay clean.
I've said that to I,
you know,
I always said that that's a,
it's an old Motorhead song or it's part of it.
So it's the lyrics of a Motorhead song.
And in WWE I used to tell whenever somebody tells me all,
you know,
I,
I've been drink,
I was drinking,
I haven't drank for six months or I haven't,
you know,
I was doing coke and I haven't been doing coke for a first eight months.
I appreciated,
or I was a drug addict or whatever.
And this is all like online.
These people saying this stuff online and I always say,
hey man,
keep it up.
Stay clean.
Now.
I wasn't thinking about the literally staying clean,
but now we have a proper soap that will help you stay clean.
Hasn't been a 12 year old kid with a business.
That's pretty impressive.
It's pretty late.
That's legit.
I was like the furthest thing from my mind at 12 do you think about what you
doing here with your cloth?
I would.
I would with my friend Jeff.
I would,
when people were going to put their trays away in lunch,
we would collect their leftover potato chips and then eat them all.
I don't know.
You're going to say he was like put them in bags so we have a pile of potato
chips on our tray and we'd just
a different was I think in about running a business was I think about trying to
build a business.
No,
I was eating massive amounts of potato chips,
which is just,
other shoes were where I was at.
Other view that I didn't even pay for.
I thought it was so awesome.
Free potato chips,
because remember when you're a kid,
your parents weren't getting you potato chips all the time have definitely a
mound of potatoes was more,
almost more than you could eat.
But we did our best to eat in the morning.
Yeah,
so that's it.
That's a warrior kid books also discipline equals freedom field manual.
Get it for people that you actually care about and want to have better lives.
That's people that you want to win in their lives.
The discipline equals freedom manual.
We'll give them a very good indication and the reason I know that is,
well,
let's not even take my experiences from my life,
but the feedback I'm getting right now,
people are getting after it.
They're losing weight or gaining weight or,
or getting more disciplined in their school,
in their life and the business because they're getting better straight out.
So you can get that and it will show you how.
Why?
Because it's a field manual.
You don't know what that is.
Echo,
I do my favorite kind of manual.
Okay.
A field manual actually gives you instructions in the military.
You weren't in the military.
You want to know nothing about a field manual.
Hey,
if you want the audio version of that,
it is not on all level.
It's not on audible.
You can't get it there.
It's on Itunes,
it's on Amazon music,
it's on Google play.
Other MP3 platforms.
It's an album with track so that you can use that thing for your alarm clock
too.
You can put it in your mixed tape in your,
what's it called?
What's it called?
It was clay.
Let me
put it in your playlist now.
You can just have it in there.
Yeah,
so if you boom,
pick the ones that you like that hits you the right way.
Also,
extreme ownership,
combat leadership principles that you can apply to your business and your life.
Other people are doing it.
That's why that book is still on the Wall Street Journal bestsellers list.
It's over two years old.
It's still there rocking.
And also with that book,
if you don't,
just get it to yourself for yourself,
get it for your team,
up and down the chain of command.
It's gonna make your life easier if you put it up and down the chain of command.
If everyone in your team is taking ownership,
we have a good team.
If you need some help with leadership at your company,
I have a leadership and management consulting company.
It's called echelon front.
We solve problems through leadership and we do it all the time and we do it all
over the world.
Me,
Leif,
Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke,
email info@echelonfrontdotcomoryoucangotoourwebsiteechelonfront.com.
Of course we have the muster I through.
I'm going to throw this out there.
The ultimate leadership conference.
That's what I'm calling it.
The ultimate leadership conference and really conference.
It might not even be the right word.
It's just,
it's embedded knowledge that's going to come at you.
It's an experience gathering.
It's a gathering.
There's no green room.
I haven't said that lately.
There's no green room at the muster.
That is a good point.
There is no bad.
I know.
That's why I've reminded myself cause I was thinking about it.
Okay.
Well why would people want to come to this?
Well,
one reason is there's no green room.
There's no backstage.
We're out there.
We're with you.
You come to the monster.
We're hanging out,
we're having lunch,
we're having dinner,
we're asking,
answering questions.
We're with you there the whole time we've done four so far they've all sold out.
We're only doing two this year.
A lot of people are objecting to this.
We don't have time to do more.
We're only doing two Washington DC,
May 17th and 18th and San Francisco October 17th 18th that's it.
We are not a rock and roll band on tour.
As much as I want to be sure.
Cause people are saying well why don't you come to Seattle and why don't you
come to Milwaukee and why don't you come to Norfolk and why don't you come to
Memphis?
Like we're on a rock tour.
Like we're just making dates.
No,
this is a the only two we're doing Washington DC May 17th and 18th and October
17th and 18th in San Francisco was the dates we can fit the muster in to our
schedule.
And like I said,
they're going to sell out.
So if you want to come registered extreme ownership.com we'll see you there.
And until the muster,
if you want to continue this conversation with any of us who you can find us
conversing on the inner webs on Twitter,
on Instagram,
and on batch Faci Baja.
Mike Ritland is at m Rit,
Linde.
And also as he said,
Mike ritland.com of course,
echo is at echocharles and I am at Jocko Willink.
Echo.
Anything else?
No thank you.
Actually I'm where you are.
We're at with the dog thing where it's like,
hey,
we can't get a dog.
We gotta be ready to get a dog,
you know,
to my daughters look good a dog.
She didn't know.
She's fine.
It's a big deal.
But I don't know man.
You know,
talking to you is kind of like,
yeah,
really.
I think I could do,
I dunno.
He's kind of very influential.
I mean,
I can tell you you can't.
it's like with anything in your life like do,
if you want to do it,
you'll do it.
You got to decide I'm going to do it,
I'm going to do it right and you'll do it.
But the only thing I would caution against is that,
realize that,
that that's carving out a portion of your day,
a portion of your life that something else isn't going to be able to fill that
prioritization component.
But yeah.
But yeah,
man,
it's so cool to me from,
thank you.
Oh,
Thanks for having me.
I appreciate it.
Mike,
you got anything else?
No,
that's it.
Just A,
I guess keep,
keep up the good fight.
I,
uh,
I am honored to be on here and appreciative of,
of your guys's time has been been great.
Well,
Mike,
Again,
thanks for coming on.
Thanks for everything you've done while you were in,
since you've been out and everything that you're continuing to do today.
I know the dogs have saved a lot of lives.
Yeah.
And appreciate that.
Of course.
Thanks to all the service men and women out there and the all go ahead and yes,
throw out a special thanks to all the dogs out there and their handlers.
Everyone in the military,
standing face to face with evil.
Thank you for standing.
The watch for police law enforcement again,
and their dogs,
firefighters,
paramedics,
all the other first responders.
Thanks for protecting us while we sleep at night
and to everyone.
Thank you for listening and sharing and supporting this podcast.
But most of all,
thanks for getting up early every day by seven negative and attacking the world
with the ferocity of an angry working dog that is out for blood and vengeance.
Go and get after it.
And until next time,
this is Mike Ritland and echo and Jocko out.